CONVENE OUR INFORMATIONAL
HEARING FOR THIS EVENING. OF
THIS AFTERNOON FOR UTILITY AND
ENERGY WERE FOCUSING ON THE
TWENTY TWENTY INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITY WHILE FIRE MITIGATION
PLANS. AND WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO THESE PRESENTATIONS
AND SO WHAT I'M GONNA DO IS
JUST MAKE A FEW OPENING
COMMENTS- THEN WE WERE GOING TO
WE'RE GOING TO GET STARTED. WE
HAVE A GOOD GREAT PANEL- THAT'S
GOING TO BE ASSEMBLED AND I
THINK IT'LL BE VERY-
INFORMATIVE FOR ALL OF US I'D
LIKE TO ALSO THANK THE- MEMBERS
AND- THOSE WHO ARE ON THE WHO
ARE HERE AND THOSE WHO ARE ON
THEIR WAY- THE PUBLIC FOR BEING
HERE TODAY. OF THE MOST
CRITICAL ISSUES FACING THIS
COMMITTEE IS ENSURING THAT
WE'VE TAKEN THE STEPS NECESSARY
TO REDUCE. RISK AN OCCURRENCE
OF CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES
IGNITED BY UTILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE. THE FOUNDATION
OF THAT WORK IS EMBODIED IN THE
I OWE YOU WHILE FIRE MITIGATION
PLANS. WHICH ARE THE FOCUS OF
TODAY'S HEARING. AND THE LAST
TWO LEGISLATIVE SESSIONS
LEGISLATURE HAS SIGNIFICANTLY
EXPANDED THE IMPORT AND
REQUIREMENTS OF THE PLANS IN
THE C. B. CEBU CITY HAS
CONTINUE TO ENHANCE. AND REFINE
PLAN ELEMENTS AND OVERSIGHT.
THE TWENTY TWENTY PLANS WERE
FILED IN FEBRUARY IN THE C. P.
U. C. NEWLY CREATED WHILE FIRE
SAFETY DIVISION IS IN THE
PROCESS OF REVIEWING THOSE
PLANS WITH THE INTENT OF
FINALIZING THAT EFFORT BY JUNE.
THIS ISN'T A ONE TIME EFFORT.
THE PLANS AND RELATED SAFETY
WORK BY CAL FIRE- YES AND CEBU
CITY AND OTHER STATE AND LOCAL
AGENCIES ARE NOW EMBEDDED. AS
PRIORITIES IN THE STATE. WE
WILL ALSO DISCUSS IN PART TWO
OF HERE OF THE HEARING. THE
WORK OF THE ARE USED TO REDUCE
THE SCOPE DURATION AND
FREQUENCY OF PS PS OF THAT'S-
UNFORTUNATE. YET NECESSARY TOOL
AS WOMEN CLIMATE CHANGE CHANGE
CONTINUE TO WREAK HAVOC ON OUR
STATE. I DO ASK MEMBERS AND
PRESENTERS TO DO THEIR BEST TO
KEEP QUESTIONS ABOUT PS PS
ADVANCE COMMUNITY OUTREACH
EXETER A TWO PART TWO OF THIS
HEARING THESE HEARINGS WILL
HAVE THE SAME PANEL- BUT WE'RE
GOING TO FOCUS ON THE FIRST
pWILL BE. ON THE S. P. S. A
TODAY WE HAVE THE THREE LARGEST
ELECTRICAL CORPORATIONS BEFORE
US 2% KEY ELEMENTS. OF THE REP
RESPECTED PLANS WE ALSO REALLY
WANT TO HEAR. ABOUT BEARS TO
FULL EXECUTION OF THE PLANS.
WE'VE WE HAVE INVITED A FEW
MEMBERS WHO ARE NOT ON THE
COMMITTEE TO JOIN US TODAY
SOMEONE MEMBERS AGUIAR-CURRY
BAUER K. HAND AND WOOD. I'D
ALSO LIKE TO SAY BEFORE WE
START OF THE OFFICIAL PART OF
OUR HEARING- TO ALLOW A GOOD
FRIEND OF- THIS ASSEMBLY AND
ALSO OUTSTANDING PUBLIC SERVANT
IN OUR SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION- TONY THURMOND- TO
SHARE SOME BRIEF COMMENTS
AROUND THE P. S. P. S. EVENTS
BECAUSE WE KNOW YOU CAN'T STAY
THROUGH THE DIRECTION OF THE
MEANING. AND TO GIVE US YOUR
PERSPECTIVE ON HOW OF THESE
OCCURRENCES ARE IMPACTING ON
OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE SO IF YOU'D LIKE TO
JOIN US YOU CAN LEAD US OFF
MAYBE ABOUT FIVE MINUTES FOR
YOU AND YOUR TEAM TO- MAKES
YOUR- AND THEN WE WILL. HOLD ON
TO THOSE THOUGHTS AS WE MAKE
OUR WAY THROUGH THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- TONY
THURMOND STATE SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION. I'M
JOINED BY ONE REALIZE WHO HEADS
UP OUR FACILITIES DIVISION AND
HAS BEEN- OUR LEAD PERSON-
WORKING WITH THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES AND OTHERS
DURING TIMES OF WHILE FIRING
HILL. AT A FEW PERSPECTIVE-
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
JUST SHARE AN APPLE FIVE FEW
THE EXPERIENCES OF OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN THE THINGS THAT.
THEY EXPERIENCE A DURING WHILE
SEASON IN P. S. P. S. EVENTS-
DOES IT. WOULD SEEM OBVIOUS TO
YOU THAT SCHOOLS ARE IMPACTED
JUST LIKE EVERY OTHER ASPECT OF
OUR COMMUNITY. AND TAKE IT
REALLY HARD WHEN THERE IS LOSS
OF LIFE- LOSS OF POWER A LOSS
OF OPPORTUNITY TO ENSURE THAT
OUR STUDENTS ARE GETTING A
GREAT EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE. I
LIKE TO SAY AT THE OUTSET THAT
WE'RE GRATEFUL- TO MANY OF THE
I. O. U.'S HAVE BEEN IN
COMMUNICATION WITH US DIRECTLY-
AND SCHOOLS AND ACCEPTED OUR
INVITATION. TO TALK ABOUT THE
EXPERIENCE OF OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND HOW WE KEEP THAT-
AT THE FOREFRONT OF THEIR MIND-
SEE- WORK WITH THIS COMMITTEE
AND LEGISLATORS ON PLANS- TO-
MANAGE FUTURE. NEEDS YOUR
AGENDA IS FULL- AND WE NOW
THAT THERE ARE MANY ITEMS THAT
HAVE TO BE COVERED BUT WE
APPRECIATE. THAT SCHOOLS-
CONTINUE TO BE IN THAT
CONVERSATION. AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
STRUGGLE FROM THE RANGE OF
THINGS THAT COME UP ONE IT'S
JUST KNOWING WHAT TO EXPECT
ABOUT WHAT PARTS OF COMMUNITIES
MIGHT BE- WITHOUT POWER- IN THE
BILL WE NEED TO HAVE. A CLEAR
INFORMATION AND MAPS AND TIMELY
INFORMATION ABOUT WHERE POWER
SAFETY SET OFF WILL OCCUR. IS
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE
HEARD- I WOULD SAY THE LOUDEST
FROM OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS THEY
LIKE TO HAVE MORE OF THAT. WHEN
IT COMES TO THE ACTUAL PS PS
ADVANCE SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN
REALLY CLEAR. HAVE GENERATORS
IN MANY DON'T AND SO IT BECOMES
A CHALLENGE TO PROVIDE
EDUCATION WITHOUT ANY POWER- SO
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT ARE
ARE FEEL THAT THEY CAN SAFELY
REMAIN OPEN. DURING THE YES BE
YES THEY THE SCHOOLS WILL SAY
US THAT TIME WHAT THE- HAS BEEN
CLASSROOMS ARE WITH THE- HEAT
NOT ALWAYS THE BEST LIGHTING-
DIDN'T INABILITY TO KEEP FOOD-
PRESERVE FOR. STUDENTS MEALS-
AND SO AS YOU CAN IMAGINE
THEY'RE ALL KINDS OF
CHALLENGES- THAT DISTRICTS
FACE. DURING THESE TIMES- OF
CHALLENGE IN SO THAT WE WOULD
ASK THAT YOUCONTINUE AS YOU
MAKE THESE PLANS. TO CONSIDER
NEEDS A SCHOOL AND THEN ALSO
ULTIMATELY THE QUESTION THAT WE
HEAR FROM DISTRICTS IS HOW DO
WE ADDRESS THE LOSS OF
INSTRUCTION TIME. AND SO WHILE
THAT MAY NOT BE- AT THE TOP OF
THE LIST FOR THIS COMMITTEE WE
HOPE THAT YOU WILL CONSIDER ALL
THESE ITEMS IN THE IMPACT IT
HAS. ON OUR ABILITY TO SUPPORT
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND TO
SUPPORT OUR SIX MILLION
STUDENTS IN THE STATE- LIKE TO.
GIVE MISTER ROSS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY GIVE ME JUST
ANOTHER MINUTE OR TWO OF
EMPHASIS ON SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WE HAVE HEARD FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF OUR SCHOOLS
THANK YOU. AFTER MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OVERALL LAST YEAR WE
HAD OVER FIFTEEN HUNDRED
SCHOOLS CLOSED NUMBER IMPACTING
OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
STUDENTS. AND WHAT IT IS UNDER
YOUR SHIP OUR STATE
SUPERINTENDENT HELD A
CONFERENCE CALL WITH TWENTY
THREE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS.
HERE FROM THEN WHAT IS THE
STATUS OF SCHOOLS TO HEAR WHAT
THE CHALLENGES ARE. AND THE
NUMBER ONE ISSUE ON THAT WE
HEARD FROM THE SCHOOLS THAT DID
REMAIN OPEN WHAT'S HAVE AXES-
GENERATORS- MAYBE SCHOOL NOT
JUST LIKE THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT GEN AND THIS
IMPACTS EMMONS. AWAY I'M IS
REFER PATIENTS FOR FOOD BUT THE
STATE'S WHICH ANIME. BUT ALSO
MANAGE. FOR STUDENTS TO HAVE
SPECIAL NEEDS FOR MEDICATION.
SOME SCHOOLS SPECIAL RULES
SCHOOLS RUN ON WELL SYSTEMS.
THEY NEED ELECTRIC PUMPS TO
HAVE FLOWING WATER MANY OF THEM
DID NOT. AND AS ANOTHER FACTOR
THAT THEY HAD TO CONSIDER WHEN
CLOSING SCHOOLS. AND SOMETIMES
THESE ISSUES WENT BEYOND THE
SCHOOL CAMPUSES THEMSELVES-
TRANSPORTATION OF THERE'S NO
FUEL IF THE GAS- GET THERE'S
GUYS THERE'S NO GASOLINE FOR
THAT BUSES THEY CAN TRANSPORT
STUDENTS. AND EVEN SOME TRAFFIC
LIGHTS YOU KNOW BEYOND THE
SCHOOLS IF THERE'S NO TRAFFIC
IT BECAME A VERY FOR SCHOOLS
FOR STUDENTS TO WALK TO SCHOOL
SAFELY- OVERALL IT THE STATE'S
A PLAN MENTION. HAVING AXIS TWO
GENERATORS WAS A BIG FACTOR IN
REMAINING OPEN. AND WE DID HEAR
FROM SOME OF OUR COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS THAT THEY DID
NOT RECEIVE. A TIMELY AND
ACCURATE INFORMATION WHICH IS
CRITICAL FOR THEM TO PLAN
ACCORDINGLY WHEN MAKING
DETERMINATIONS TO CLOSE
SCHOOLS. AND TO COMMUNICATE
WITH THE PARENTS AND THE
COMMUNITY. AND WITH THAT I'D
LIKE TO. ASK ME QUESTIONS. IT
WAS WE SUBMITTED A QUESTION
FROM YOUR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WELL THANK YOU- I
THINK PROBABLY THE BEST WAY TO
PROCEED IS THAT. YOU RAISE A
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE AND WITH
YOUR JURISDICTION AND ALL OF
OUR CONCERN WE NEED TO. MAKE
SURE THEY WERE PAYING ATTENTION
TO HOW THESE ISSUES IMPACT ON
ON SCHOOLS AS WELL AS-
HOSPITALS AND OTHER FACILITIES
AROUND COMMUNITIES THAT ARE.
ARE VERY IMPORTANT- TO MAKE
SURE POWER IS SOMEWHERE IS
MAKING ITS WAY TO THAT LOCATION
WHAT I WOULD. SUGGEST BECAUSE I
THINK THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
SHARE TODAY AND WE WILL HOPE.
PASS ALONG YOUR THOUGHTS I KNOW
THAT THE REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
UTILITIES WHO ARE HERE TODAY.
ARE TAKING NOTE- BUT THE CPSC
IS REVIEWING THESE WELL FOR
MANY YEARS AND PLANS AND IT
THERE'S A PROCESS THAT YOU CAN
A SUPERINTENDENT ON BEHALF OF
THE SCHOOLS IN THIS DISTRICT
KIND OF OUTLINE- SPECIFIC
ISSUES AS YOU'VE DONE HERE
TODAY. THAT WOULD PROBABLY BE
VERY INSTRUCTIVE TO THE AGENCY
AS IT GOES THROUGH ITS PROCESS
AND HAS ITS COMMENTS BACK TO
THE UTILITY SO. I WOULD JUST
MAKE THAT SUGGESTION AS A WAY
TO FURTHER. YOUR COMMUNICATION
AND GETTING INFORMATION OUT ALL
PAUSE IF THERE'S ANY OTHER
MEMBER THAT WOULD LIKE TO ASK A
QUESTION BUT- WE'RE GIVING YOU
THE COURTESY BECAUSE- YOU
DESERVE THE COURTESY IN YOUR
WELL AS A FORMER MEMBER YOU
ALWAYS HAVE PRIVILEGES AROUND
HERE- BUT WE WILL STAY IN
CONTACT WITH YOU AND- CERTAINLY
BE HELPFUL ALONG THE WAY TO. TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE VOICE OF THE
CHILDREN IN THE SCHOOLS IN THIS
DISTRICT HEARD. THINGS CHAIR
AND- WE WILL ACT ON YOUR
SUGGESTION I WOULD SAY THAT THE
STAFF OF THIS COMMITTEE HAS
BEEN PARTICULARLY HELPFUL IF WE
COULD WORK WITH THEM ON HOW TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN OR YOU KNOW WE
HAVE ACCESS TO THE YOU KNOW THE
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS AND THEIR
DISTRICTS. AND THEN THEIR
ASSOCIATIONS THAT REPRESENT THE
MORE THAN A THOUSAND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS SO WE'RE FAIRLY
CONFIDENT THAT IT WOULD BE EASY
FOR US TO GET FEEDBACK AND
ENGAGE FOLKS BUT WE CAN WORK
WITH YOUR STAFF ON HOW TO MAKE
THE CONNECTION DIRECTLY. WITH
THE RIGHT FOLKS TO THE CPUC
WOULD BE HAPPY TO MAKE SURE
THAT PERSPECTIVE IS INCLUDED
DONE DEAL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M SORRY. PRESS I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF
SUPERINTENDENT FOR PROVIDING
THIS INFORMATION BUT I WOULD
HOPE THAT DURING THE SECOND
SESSION THE HAVING HEARD THE
CONCERNS OF REGARDING OUR
SCHOOLS THAT THE FOOD THE
PRESENTERS A PANELIST WILL
ADDRESS THIS. THANK YOU THAT'S
REQUEST. THANKS SO MUCH THANK
YOU. SO LET'S MOVE TO OUR FIRST
PANEL AND THAT PESENTATION IS
ON THE WELFARE MITIGTION PLANS
AND I'LL CALL FOR THE PANELISTS
A JOHN JENKINS WHO IS THE VICE
PRESIDENT. ELECTRIC SYSTEMS
OPERATION FOR SAN DIEGO GAS AND
ELECTRIC BILL HARRINGTON SENIOR
VICE PRESIDENT OF TRANSITION
TRANSMISSION AND DISTRIBUTION
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON.
DEBRA POWELL VICE PRESIDENT
ASSET RISK MANAGEMENT AND
COMMUNITY WHAT WILD FIRE SAFETY
PROGRAM. FOR PACIFIC GAS AND
ELECTRIC AND MATTHEW PENDER
DIRECTOR COMMUNITY WHILE FIRE
SAFETY PROGRAM THE CIVIC GAS
AND ELECTRIC. WILL WE WELCOME
ALL OF YOU AND IF YOU CAN MAKE
YOUR PRESENTATION IN THE ORDER
OF WHICH YOU WERE CALLED UP.
THERE WILL BEGIN. ALL RIGHT-
I'LL BE READY. WE ARE READY
OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JOHN JENKINS I'M SAN DIEGO GAS
ELECTRIC SPICE PRESIDENT OF
ELECTRICITY TO OPERATIONS AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
MISTER CHAIR. IS A BETTER OKAY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COME HERE AND PRESENT TO THE
OTHER MEMBERS TODAY AN OVERVIEW
OF SD GINNY'S WILDFIRE
MEDICATION PLAN. OF YOU GO TO
THE FIRST SLIDE IN THE DECK-
THIS IS JUST TO HELP PROVIDE
SOME CONTEXT ABOUT OUR SERVICE
TERRITORY- SO. OUTLINED IN THE
IN THE BRIGHT RED LINE IS AS
DISNEY'S FORTY ONE HUNDRED
SQUARE MILES OF SERVICE
TERRITORY THAT COVERS SAN DIEGO
COUNTY IN THE SOUTHERN PART OF
ORANGE COUNTY- WITHIN THAT
READ. BOLDED LINE- YOU SEE THE
YELLOW SHADED AREA THAT'S OUR
HIGH FIRE THREAT DISTRICT HERE
TOO. AND THEN WITHIN THAT THE-
PINK SHADED AREA IS OUR HIGH
FIRED THREAT DISTRICT HERE
THREE- AND THIS COMPRISES 64%
OF THOSE FORTY ONE HUNDRED
SQUARE MILES THAT I MENTIONED
WE ALSO HAVE A SIXTY FIVE
HUNDRED OVERHEAD ABOVE CIRCUIT
MILES. THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED OF
THOSE MILES ARE IN THE HYPER
THREAT DISTRICT- WE HAVE ONE
POINT OVER ONE POINT THREE
MILLION ELECTRIC METERS THAT WE
SERVE A TUNER SIX THOUSAND
THOSE- RESIDE IN THE HIGHER
THREAT DISTRICT. WE HAVE ONE
HUNDRED NINETY ONE WEATHER
STATIONS THAT GIVE US REAL TIME
WEATHER INFORMATION AND-
SMALLER MICROCLIMATE AREAS TO
HELP US MAKE- OPERATIONAL
DECISIONS AND GIVE US
INFORMATION TO AND FORMER
MITIGATION EFFORTS. AND ANOTHER
UNIQUE ASPECT OF OUR SERVICE
TERRITORY AS WE DO HAVE 61% OF
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE IS
UNDERGROUND- HOWEVER THE
MAJORITY THAT IS COASTAL- SO
MORE OUTSIDE OF THE HYPER
THREAT DISTRICT. AND WE HAVE
FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND
TREES THAT WE INVENTORY IN OUR
DATABASE AND 53% OF THOSE
VEGETATION ASSETS FROM THE
HYPER THREAT DISTRICT. NEXT
SLIDE OF ONE MORE SLIDE ON TO
PROVIDE SOME CONTEXT AS TO THE
CHANGING CONDITIONS- THIS IS A
TOOL THAT THAT WE DEVELOPED A
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO CALLED THE
SANTA ANA WILDFIRE THREAD INDEX
IN THE STATES- THIS- TRACKS.
THE INDEX BACK TO NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR- AND YOU CAN SEE
THE RISE AND OCCURRENCES AND
FREQUENCY OF OCCURRENCES. OF
EXTREME WEATHER CONDITIONS AND
TO AS NOTED ON THE SLIDE
FIFTEEN OF THE TWENTY. FIVE
MOST DESTRUCTIVE FIRES IN THE
STATE'S HISTORY OF OCCURRED
SINCE TWO THOUSAND. NOW MOVING
ON TO- THE- IGNITION CAUSES- I
WOULD LIKE TO CLARIFY THAT THIS
INFORMATION IS SYSTEM WIDE SO
OBVIOUSLY THE MAJORITY OF OUR
MITIGATION EFFORTS- AND
PROCEDURES THAT WE HAVE DURING
ELEVATED CONDITIONS OCCUR IN
THE HYPER THREAT DISTRICT BUT
THIS- THIS TABLE IS SYSTEM
WIDE- AND- GOES THROUGH THE
VARIOUS CONTACT- CAUSES. OF OUR
IGNITIONS IN OUR SERVICE
TERRITORY- AND YOU CAN SEE THE
TOTALS OF THE BOTTOM GOING FROM
THIRTY IN 200-015-2215 IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN- THE PART OF
THE PIE CHART ON THE RIGHT.
GOES OVER- THE CAUSES FOR THE
LAST FIVE YEARS AND PERCENTAGES
SO WE HAVE 35% THAT ARE BECAUSE
FROM FROM EQUIPMENT ISSUES. AND
IT'S 65% OF SOME SORT OF
CONTACT WITH WITH OUR LINES
FROM FOR LARGER OBJECTS SUCH AS
A- MYLAR BALLOONS. NOW MOVING
ON TO THE- ACTIVITIES THAT ARE
IN OUR TWENTY TWENTY WILD FIRE
MITIGATION PLAN- THERE ARE
SIXTY FIVE ACTIVITIES THAT ARE
IN THE PLAN THESE ARE A-
HIGHLIGHTS OF SOME OF THE MAIN
ACTIVITIES THAT THAT ARE
OCCURRING- THE FIRST TWO. OF
WE'LL START WITH THE FIRST ONE
SAYS HARDENING OF AS PART OF
THE EVOLUTION OF OUR MITIGATION
EFFORTS WE ARE INCORPORATING
MORE UNDERGROUND IN THIS PLAN.
OF THE REASON FOR THAT BEING IS
WE HAVE CERTAIN PARTS OF OUR
TERRITORY THAT HAVE. THE
TERRAIN AND FUELS AND WHEN
CONDITIONS WORSE- CONSISTENTLY
SEE ONE SPEEDS OVER SIXTY MILES
AN HOUR WORDS JUST HARD FOR US
TO GET COMFORTABLE WITH HAVING
OVERHEAD. ENERGIZED FACILITIES
THERE EVEN IF IT'S COVERED
CONDUCTOR WITH. REPLACING HIGH
RISK EQUIPMENT WITH VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT ON ALL THOSE THINGS
ARE STILL AN INHERENT RISK
HAVING ENERGIZED FACILITIES
OVERHEAD IN. IN THOSE REALLY
RISKY AREAS. ANOTHER PART OF
OUR UNDERGROUND IN IS WHAT WE
CALL DIRECT UNDER GROUNDING AND
WHAT THIS IS EXPRESS
UNDERGROUND CIRCUITS OUT TO
SOME OF THESE BACK COUNTRY
COMMUNITY CENTERS. SO WE WOULD
UNDERGROUND JUST THOSE
COMMUNITIES. AND UNDER FEEDER
THOSE SO WE COULD KEEP.
CRITICAL FACILITIES ON TO
SCHOOLS- AS JUST MENTION THE
OPENING REMARKS OF STORES-
URGENT CARE CENTERS- COMMUNITY
CENTERS WHERE PEOPLE CAN GO
DURING DURING THESE EVENTS AND-
SO THAT'S INCORPORATED IN OUR
UNDERGROUND AS WELL IN THE
CANTEEN WITH THEIR OVERHEAD.
HARDENING EFFORTS WITH THAT
WITH A HUNDRED FORTY FIVE MILES
OF OVERHEAD HARDENING INCLUDING
BEAR AND COVER CONDUCTOR. OVER
THE THREE YEAR PERIOD- WE'RE
GOING TO BE INSTALLING A THIRTY
ADDITIONAL WEATHER STATIONS TO.
PROVIDE MORE INFORMATION FOR US
TO BE EVEN MORE PRECISE THEM
ARE ARE AND IN. THAT INSTEAD OF
US HAS FIVE CUSTOMERS. ONCE
EACH THE PROP CONDITION WERE
THE ROOT IS HI THE END. THAT
MAYBE CALL DOWN TO THREE
HUNDRED SO AN EXAM OF USING. H.
INCOME WITH THE LIES BASIS. WE
ARE ALL WHY WE HAVE OVER ONE
THIRD OF MOUNTAIN TOP I'M A
RENT DEFINITION CAN WERE GOING
TO BE IMPROVING THE TECH AND
THE TO COMMUNICATE TO THOSE AND
THIS THERE VALUABLE TOOL FOR A
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THEY THE
TO STAY CLEAN WITH AND THE BUT
THE LATEST TECHNOLOGY POSSIBLE.
AND THEN MOVING ON TO ENHANCE
VEGETATION. THAT WE DEVELOP THE
VEGETATION RISK INDEX IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN- THROUGH THE
DATA ANALYSIS OF THE DATA AND
OUR DATABASE WE'VE IDENTIFIED
FIVE SPECIES OF TREES THAT ARE
MORE PROBLEMATIC THAN OTHERS-
PINE PALM OAK EUCALYPTUS AND
SICK MARKED A TO BE PRECISE-
AND WE'RE LOOKING TO GO. BEYOND
OUR TWELVE TO FIFTEEN FEET OF
HOSE TRIM CLARENCE THAT WE
CURRENTLY GET- TO UP TO TWENTY
FIVE FEET DEPENDING ON THE
SITUATION AND SO WE'RE TRYING
TO- DO THAT TO FIFTY ONE
THOUSAND OF OUR FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND TREES-
IN THIS TIME PERIOD- THAT'S IN
THIS TIME PERIOD. I WERE ALSO
DOING SOME FUELS MANAGEMENT-
WHERE WE HAD WE STARTED A PILOT
PROGRAM LAST YEAR WHERE WE-
AGAIN IN THE REALLY RISKY AREAS
WE HAVE SOME FUEL BEDS THAT WE
WANTED TO CLEAR TO REDUCE THE
POSSIBLE SOURCE CAN IGNITION.
US WITH THAT FOR TWENTY FIVE
MILES IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
SO WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE THAT
PROGRAM OVER THE- THE THREE
YEAR PERIOD HERE- ADVANCED
PROTECTION. OF FIFTY FIVE.
SUBSTATIONS A IN OUR HIGH FIRE
THREAT DISTRICT. OF THIS TWENTY
WILL HAVE ALMOST EVERY
SUBSTATION WOULD HAVE ADVANCED
PROTECTION CAPABILITIES NOW AND
WHAT THAT MEANS. AS WE HAVE
COMMUNICATION TO THOSE
SUBSTATIONS AND COMMUNICATION
FROM THE SUBSTATIONS OUT TO THE
PROTECTIVE DEVICES ON THE
LINES. IT HELPS TO ENABLE OUR
SINCE THE PROFILE PROTECTION
WHICH- THE QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE-
IDENTIFIES FAULTS AND ISOLATES
THEM LIMITING THE AMOUNT OF
ENERGY AVAILABLE OBVIOUSLY
LIMITING THE- A POSSIBLE SOURCE
OF IGNITION. IT ALSO ENABLES
ARE FALLING CONDUCTOR
PROTECTION SO IF SOMETHING
COMES IN CONTACT WITH OUR
LINES. BRINGS THE LINE DOWN IT
WILL BE ENERGIZED THE LINE
BEFORE IT HITS THE GROUND
OBVIOUSLY- MITIGATING THE
POSSIBILITY ENDING MISSION THAT
SITUATION I TALKED ABOUT THE S.
ACTUALIZING DEVICES IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE WEATHER
STATIONS- THERE'S DEFINITELY.
DEFINITELY PS PS BENEFITS TO
THAT- WE'LL TALK ABOUT THAT IN
THE SECOND PRESENTATION. OF
MICRO BRAIDS- SIMILAR TO MY
DIRECT AROUND HIM OR WE'RE
GONNA UNDERGROUND SOME
COMMUNITY CENTERS TO PROVIDE
SOME CRITICAL GOODS AND
SERVICES TO THE BACK COUNTRY
COMMUNITIES- SOMETIMES IT'S
MORE COST EFFECTIVE TO DO THOSE
THROUGH MY CORPORATE SO WE'LL
DO IT OF. A DEPLOYED
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY RESOURCE
SUCH AS GENERATION OR ENERGY
STORAGE- TO BE THE SOURCE- FOR
THOSE COMMUNITY CENTERS AND SO
THERE ARE. SEVEN MICROPHONES
PLAN OVER THE YEAR PERIOD FOR
THOSE WILL BE INSTALLED AND IN
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY AND THEN A
COUPLE OF OTHER- GENERATOR
PROGRAMS WE HAVE A- MEDICAL
BASS LINE GENERATOR PROGRAM
THAT WE STARTED IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WILL BE OFFERED A-
BATTERY STORAGE UNIT IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE PORTABLE
SOLAR PANELS SO THEY COULD
RECHARGE DURING THE DAY- TO
PROVIDE EMERGENCY SOURCE. OF
FOR PEOPLE WITH NEBULIZERS
AUCTION TANKS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT. WE'RE GONNA EXPAND THAT
PROGRAM OF IN THIS THREE YEAR
PERIOD. AND IN LOOKING AT SOME
BEHIND THE METER SOLUTIONS TO
SOAR GONNA PILOT- SOME
DIFFERENT- TYPES OF GENERATION
SO WE'RE GONNA LOOK AT. ENERGY
STORED ROOFTOP SOLAR
CONJUNCTION WITH ENERGY
STORAGE- EVEN POSTLE FUEL
GENERATION- THERE CERTAIN
SITUATIONS THAT WE HAVE FIVE
MILES A BLIND FEE. FIVE TO TEN
CUSTOMERS IT JUST ISN'T
ECONOMICALLY VIABLE TO HARDEN
THAT LINE FOR THAT NUMBER
CUSTOMERS. SO TO HELP MITIGATE
THE EFFECTS OF PS PS WILL BE
LOOKING AT BEHIND THE METER
SOLUTIONS TO PROVIDE THEM POWER
DURING THOSE SITUATIONS. AND
THEN THE LAST SLIDE IS JUST THE
FINANCIALS THAT ARE- GO ALONG
WITH THE ACTIVITIES THAT I JUST
DESCRIBED AND WE HAVE THE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN ACTUAL AS
WHICH WE- A SPENT IN THOSE
CATEGORIES- COMPARED TO. WHAT'S
PLANNED FOR TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
AND THEN WHAT'S INCORPORATED IN
THE- THREE YEAR TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY THROUGH TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY TWO PLAN- WHICH IS A
TOTAL OF APPROXIMATELY NINE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
CAPITAL OVER THE THREE YEARS
FOR SAN DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC. I
WE HOLDING THE QUESTIONS TILL
THE END OR WE CAN. OKAY ONCE
ALL OF YOUR CREDIT. OKAY GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE HOLD AND-
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS IN ATTENDANCE
I'M FILL HARRINGTON THE SENIOR
VICE PRESIDENT OF TRANSMISSION
AND DISTRIBUTION FOR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON UP WE WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING TODAY ALLOWING US TO
YOU THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE
THE SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS WE'VE
MAKING- IN WALL FIRE MITIGATION
AS WELL AS LESSONS LEARNED FROM
THE OCTOBER TWENTY NINETEEN P.
S. P. S. OFFENSE. WE PROVIDE
YOU WITH A PRESENTATION- I WILL
OCCASIONALLY REFERRED TO THIS
ROUTE OBVIOUSLY WE CAN ANSWER
QUESTIONS. ABOUT THE
PRESENTATION LATER BUT I WILL
NOT BE GOING TO SLIDE BY SLIDE
THROUGH THIS A RIGHT NOW. S. C.
E. HAS SAFETY IS OUR NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY AND WE ARE COMMITTED
TO CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT. TOP
IN THAT SPIRIT- WHILE WE'RE
HERE TO- SURE PLAN A PROGRAMS
WITH YOU- MOST IMPORTANT WE'RE
HERE TO LISTEN- WE NOT ONLY OF
THE YOUR FEEDBACK WE NEED YOUR
FEEDBACK AND SO- WE WANNA
CORPORATE THAT OUR PLANS GOING
FORWARD. RIGHT BEFORE- THE
INCREASING WILDFIRE RISK WAS A
PARENT- WE ARE INVESTING IN A
SMARTER MORE RESILIENT TO READ.
OVER THIS PAST DECADE WE'VE
INVESTED MORE THAN ELEVEN
BILLION DOLLAR TO. MAINTAIN
UPGRADE AND MODERNIZE. OUR
GRADE WITH STATE OF THE ART
TECHNOLOGY. THAT IMPROVES
RELIABILITY AND WILDFIRE
RESILIENCY. NOW THIS HAS THE
ADDED BENEFIT OF MAKING OUR
SYSTEM- BETTER PERFORMING IN PS
PS VETS. REDUCING THE SCOPE AND
THE SCALE THOSE OCCURRENCES.
NOW THIS HISTORY OF INVESTMENT
ALLOWS US TO SECTIONAL AS OUR
SYSTEM- WHICH IS WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT PREVIOUSLY HAS BENEFITS
IN THE P. S. P. S. EVENTS. AS
AN EXAMPLE- DURING THE EVENTS
OF LAST YEAR THE SIGNIFICANT
EVENTS OUT OF THE FIVE MILLION
CUSTOMERS OR METERED CUSTOMERS
IN OUR SERVICE TERRITORY.
AROUND A HUNDRED THOUSAND OR 2%
WERE ULTIMATELY DE ENERGIZED-
SO THAT'S EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE
ROUGHLY FOURTEEN THOUSAND
SQUARE MILES OF HIGH FIRE RISK
AREA WHICH ACCOUNTS FOR ROUGHLY
A THIRD OF OUR SERVICE AREA.
OUR EFFECTIVELY WORKING WITH
CUSTOMERS AND COMMUNITIES TO
DETERMINE HOW WE CAN MINIMIZE
THE IMPACTS OF PS PS. AND
THROUGH GREAT HARDENING AS WELL
AS OPERATIONAL CHANGES. REDUCE
THE IMPACT OF P. S. P. S. OVER
TIME. NOT HOWEVER OUT YOUR OLD
YOU MENTION THIS UNFORTUNATELY
PSP AS WILL STILL NEED TO
REMAIN AVAILABLE TO US. AS A
TOOL DURING EXTREME EVENTS. NOW
WE PROPOSED TO IN OUR TWENTY
TWENTY WHILE FIRE MITIGATION
PLAN- THAT WILL MOVE US WELL
BEYOND COMPLIANCE WITH
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS- AND
REALLY INSTEAD TOWARD DAY
IMPLEMENTING PRACTICES.
PROCEDURES OR POSITION US AS
THE INDUSTRY LEADER IN WALL
FIRE MITIGATION. NOW TODAY I'LL
DISCUSS FOR TWENTY NINETEEN
WORK- AS WELL AS OUR TWENTY
TWENTY PLAN. AND ALSO SURE WERE
ADAPTING APPROACH TO PSP A
SPACE ON COMMUNITY AND CUSTOMER
FEEDBACK. SO AFTER THE
DEVASTATING FIRES OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN- AS HE PUT FORTH THE
GRID SAFETY RESULT RESILIENCY
PROGRAM- THIS WAS WELL BEFORE
THE- SI PC WHILE FIRE
MITIGATION PLAN PROCEEDINGS WE
KNOW TODAY. WE KNEW WE NEEDED
ACT AND WE WANTED TO DO THAT
EXPEDITIOUSLY AND THOUGHTFULLY
AND THAT WAS REFLECTED IN THAT
PROGRAM. NOW SINCE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN- WE'VE INSTALLED
ROUGHLY FIVE HUNDRED MILES OF
COVER CONDUCTOR- AS A MEASURE
OF HARDING OUR INFRASTRUCTURE.
OVER FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY
WEATHER STATIONS HAVE BEEN
INSTALLED OVER THAT TIME
PERIOD. AND HUNDRED SIXTY HIGH
DEFINITION CAMERAS COVERING 90%
OF OUR HIGH FIRE RISK AREAS.
NOW WE'RE ABLE TO GO WELL
BEYOND THE COMPLIANCE TARGET SO
WE SET FORTH IN OUR TWENTY
NINETEEN WHILE FIRE MITIGATION
PLAN. AND YOU CAN SEE A LIST OF
THE PROGRESS WE'VE INCLUDED
THAT ON SLIDE FOR. NOW WE HAVE
BEEN LASER FOCUS ON DOING THE
WORK- THAT- ARE REGULATORS. AND
THIS LEGISLATOR HAS SET BEFORE
US. NOW BEYOND THAT AND AT THE
SAME TIME WE FOUND WAYS TO MORE.
THE S. SEES MOVING SWIFTLY AND
DELIBERATELY TO REDUCE RISK
BEFORE THIS NEXT THE BARS
SEASON WHICH IS NEAR UPON US.
NO THAT'S WHAT WE DID IN TWENTY
NINETEEN SELECT A SURE WITHIN
OUR PLANS FOR TWENTY TWENTY. IN
OUR TWENTY TWENTY WHILE FOR A
MITIGATION PLAN FILING WE
PROPOSE INVESTING THREE POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS THE PAST
ME. OVER THE NEXT THREE YEARS
TO REDUCE THE CHANCE THAT OUR
LOCAL SERVICE EQUIPMENT SPARKS
OF FIRE. THERE ARE TWENTY
NINETEEN IN OUR TWENTY TWENTY
PLAN EXCUSE ME WE PROPOSE
INVESTING THREE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS OVER THE NEXT
THREE YEARS TO REDUCE THE
CHANCE THAT OUR ELECTRICAL
EQUIPMENT SPARKS OF FIRE. AND
TO MITIGATE THE IMPACT OF POWER
SHUT OFFS. I'LL BE HIGHLY
DETAILS OF THAT PLAN TO
DEMONSTRATE OUR BUILDING ON
PREVIOUS WORK AS WELL AS
SIGNIFICANTLY STEPPING UP OUR
DEPLOYMENT. ACROSS OUR TIRE
PLATFORM INCLUDING INNOVATION.
THE ONLY SPEND A MOMENT ON OUR
CORE FOCUS AREAS THIS WILL NOT
BE THE ENTIRE PLAN I GO THROUGH
THERE'S A NUMBER OF A- NUMBER
PROGRAMS IN THERE THAT ARE
WORTH SPENDING TIME ON- BUT
THIS IS COVERED SLICE FIVE
THREE SIXTEEN OF THE- OF THE
PLAN THAT WE- HANDED OUT. A
COVER CONDUCT DEPLOYMENT
REMAINS REPRESENTS THE BULK OF
OUR HARDING EFFORTS. THEY WERE
PLANNING TO DEPLOY AT LEAST
SEVEN HUNDRED CIRCUIT MILES IN
TWENTY TWENTY WHICH REPRESENTS
A SIGNIFICANT. UPTICK FIVE
HUNDRED MILES OF IN STOCK FOR
THE LAST TWO YEARS. NOW WE'VE
OPPOSE IN A GROUP TO PLAN
COMPLETE APPROXIMATELY FORTY
FIVE HUNDRED MILE CIRCUIT
MILES. OF COVER CONDUCTOR BY
THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
NOW OUR ABILITY TO SEXUALIZED
AND ISOLATE CIRCUIT SEGMENTS
HAS BEEN CRITICAL TO
RELIABILITY. AND COUPLED WITH
REAL TIME WEATHER STATIONS THIS
HELPS REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
CUSTOMERS IMPACTED BY PSP YES.
THEY WILL CONTINUE TO FIND AND
TARGET SECTIONAL ICING FOR
CIRCUS TO FURTHER MITIGATE THE
IMPACT OF PS PS IN THE FUTURE.
NOW OR FOCUSED ON COST
EFFECTIVE HARDING SOLUTIONS
SUCH AS COVER CONDUCTOR. WE'RE
ALSO INCLUDING- SELECTIVE
UNDERGRAD IN AREAS TO MEET
SPECIFIC CRITERIA FOR EXAMPLE
AREAS THAT ARE ROUTINELY HIT BY
P. S. P. S. OR AREAS WHERE.
THERE CHALLENGES THE INGRESS
AND EGRESS. INSTALLATION
EXPECTED TO COMMENCE OUR
PROGRAM IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AFTER COMPLETING THE DESIGN AND
PERMITTING OF THAT WORK. NOW
MOST- IGNITIONS ARE SYSTEM
OCCUR WHEN FOREIGN OBJECTS ****
TO CONTACT OUR LINES IT'S OVER
50% SO VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
REMAINS A CORE FOCUS FOR US.
NOW WITH EXPANDED OUR TREE
LINED CLEARANCE STANDARDS AND
CONTINUE TREE REMOVALS UNDER
OUR HAS A TREE MITIGATION
PROGRAM EACH THE MP. NOW THE
FURTHER ARE WHITE WITH FARMERS
ONLY SEE ALSO- WE CREATE A
FIREBREAK AROUND OUR POLLS AND
SOMETHING CALLED THE POLL
BRUSHING PROGRAM. NOW ALSO IN
TWENTY NINETEEN WE INSPECTED
100% OF OUR OVERHEAD LINES IN
OUR HYPER RISK AREA. IN OUR
TWENTY TWENTY PLAN. OUR
OBJECTIVE IS TO PRIORITIZE THE
RE INSPECTION OF MANY OF THOSE
LINES. THE REPRESENT THE HIGHS
FIRE RISK BASED ON THE
PROBABILITY OF IGNITION AND THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THAT IGNITION.
THESE STRUCTURES WILL BE
INSPECTED ANNUALLY BOTH FROM
THE AIR AND ON THE GROUND. AND
GOING FOR THE CURRENT
REGULATORY REQUIREMENT OF FIVE
YEARS AND THREE YEARS- FIVE
YEARS FOR DISTRIBUTION OF THREE
YEARS FOR TRANSMISSION WILL
ALWAYS BE WELL EXCEEDED UNDER
THAT PROGRAM. NOW THE NEXT. SO
TALK BRIEFLY ABOUT SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS I THINK THAT'S A
COMMON WE HAVE WITH THE MEN THE
UTILITIES THAT WE ARE. LOOKING
AT THE NORTH AND SOUTH OF
COURSE- THE DEPLOYMENT HIGH
DEFINITION CAMERAS IS
ESSENTIALLY COMPLETE A SAID A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY HT CAMERAS.
AT MISSILE SO FAR AND IT
PROVIDES IS VISUAL COVERAGE OF
SIXTY OR 90% OF OUR SERVICE
TERRITORY IN HIGH FIRE RISK
AREAS. THAT'S ESSENTIALLY
SATURATION GIVEN OUR TOPOGRAPHY
AND TERRAIN SO WE REALLY CAN'T
GET ANYMORE BENEFIT FROM-
IDENTITY HIGH DEFINITION
CAMERAS. NOW WE'VE ALSO
COMPLETED INSTALLING A HUNDRED
AND TO THE FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY
TWO WEATHER STATIONS. AND THESE
DEVICES APPROVING CRITICAL- FOR
WEATHER MODELING AND
FORECASTING AND THIS ALLOWS US
TO DO MORE TARGETED DAMAGES
ASIANS- IN THE FUTURE. NOW
WE'RE PROPOSING TO INSTALL
THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
WEATHER STATIONS EACH YEAR FOR
THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS. THE
PART OF OUR PROGRAM. AND OF
COURSE WE'RE ALSO CONTINUING
DEPLOYMENT A PROMISING NEW
TECHNOLOGIES DISTRIBUTION FAULT
ANTICIPATION RAPPER EARTH FALL
CURRENT LIMITING TECHNOLOGIES.
PROBABLY REALLY REALLY PARTLY
FOR LEVERAGING THE USE OF BIG
DATA MACHINE LEARNING AND
ADVANCED ANALYTICS. NOW PORTLY
OUR TWENTY TWENTY PLAN WILL
INCLUDE SPECIFIC MEASURES TO
PROVIDE TRANSPARENCY TO THE
PUBLIC AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
AND WILL ENABLE SI PC TO
CLEARLY EVALUATE OUR PROGRESS.
THIS TRANSPARENCY BETWEEN
UTILITY ARE REGULATORS THE
LEGISLATURE AND STAKEHOLDERS IS
NECESSARY TO OUR JOINT SUCCESS.
THIS WILL LEAD TO A CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW OUR
PROPOSED MEDICATIONS ARE
REDUCING RISK AND PROTECTING
OUR CUSTOMERS FROM UNNECESSARY
COSTS. NOW THE TOPIC OF
CUSTOMER COSTS SOMETHING THAT'S
A OF DEEP CONCERN TO US ALWAYS.
OUR PRESENTATION BECAUSE A
BREAKDOWN OF THE INVESTMENTS
WERE PROPOSING TO MAKE- IN ARE
PLANNED BY CATEGORY. AND THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THESE HAVE
ALREADY BEEN COLLUDED IN OUR
GENERAL RATE CASE WHICH WAS
RECENTLY FILED- AND ARE PENDING
APPROVAL BEFORE THE CPUC. NOW
HISTORICALLY OUR ELECTRICITY
RATES HAVE RISEN- ON PAR WITH
INFLATION. HOWEVER WITH THIS
COMPREHENSIVE INVESTMENT
PROGRAM- WE EXPECT TO SEE RATES
ABOVE THAT. HOWEVER ACCORDING
TO SEE IF YOU SEE PROJECTIONS
WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE THE
LOWEST SYSTEM AVERAGE RATES. OF
THE INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA. NINE CLOSING-
SAFETY IS AS SEIZE NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY- THAT'S MY PARTY
THAT'S OUR COMPANIES PRIORITY.
SAFE YOUR PUBLIC OUR CUSTOMERS
OUR EMPLOYEES AND FIRST
RESPONDERS WHO AFTER REACT WHEN
THERE ARE FIRES IN OUR SERVICE
TERRITORY. NOW LAST YEAR WE
MADE SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS
THROUGH OUR IMPLEMENTATION
COVER AGGRESSIVE TWENTY
NINETEEN WHILE FIRE MITIGATION
PLAN. FOR TWENTY TWENTY PLAN
BILLS ON THE SUCCESS OF LAST
YEAR'S EFFORTS AND
SIGNIFICANTLY EXPANDS THE SCOPE
AND SCALE OF OUR WORK. NOW W
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE OUR MOVING SWIFTLY IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR COLLEAGUES
AT IBEW LOCAL FORTY SEVEN. TO
REDUCE THE RISK OF WILDFIRES
AND ENHANCE THE SAFETY OF OUR
PUBLIC. SO WE THANK YOU AND I
LOOK FOR YOUR QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
HOLDEN AND- GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR HOLDEN AND- COMMITTEE AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DEBBIE PAL I AM THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF P. GENIES ASSET
RISK MANAGEMENT AND COMMUNITY
WHILE FIRE SAFETY PROGRAM. MY
RESPONSIBILITIES INCLUDE
OVERSEEING MANY OF OUR
EXTENSIVE WILD FIRE SAFETY
MEASURES I'VE NEARLY THIRTY
YEARS OF ENERGY INDUSTRY AND
MILITARY EXPERIENCE. WELL I'M
NEW TO MY CURRENT ROLE I HAVE
BEEN WITH P. JEANNIE FOR A
DECADE- SERVING IN SENIOR
LEADERSHIP ROLES AND ELECTRIC
JANET- ELECTRIC OPERATIONS AND
POWER GENERATION. I'D ALSO LIKE
TO INTRODUCE MATT PENDER WHO IS
THE DIRECTOR OF OUR COMMUNITY
WHILE FIRE SAFETY PROGRAM. AND
WHILE FIRE MITIGATION PLAN. AS
I JOINED THIS TEAM RECENTLY
MATT IS HERE TO ANSWER ANY
DETAILED QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
AS AN ENERGY COMPANY THE SAFETY
OF OUR- SIXTEEN MILLION
CUSTOMERS AND THE COMMUNITIES
WE SERVE IS OUR MOST IMPORTANT
RESPONSIBILITY. WE NEED TO ACT
NOW BECAUSE THE CLIMATE IS
CHANGING. P. JEANNIE- SERVICE.
HAS CHANGED FROM 15% 252% HI
FIRE RISK AREAS THAT'S IN SEVEN
YEARS THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT
CHANGE. PROLONGED PERIODS OF
HIGH TEMPERATURES EXTREME
DRYNESS AND RECORD HIGH WINDS
HAVE CREATED CONDITIONS AND OUR
STATE WHERE ANY SPARK TO CREATE
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE. AT P.
JEANNIE WE ARE TAKING IMMEDIATE
AND COMPREHENSIVE ACTIONS TO
UPGRADE OUR INFRASTRUCTURE.
MONITOR FIRE THREATS IN REAL
TIME AN INSTITUTE NEW WILD FIRE
SAFETY MEASURES. WE ARE
IMPROVING OUR PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT SHUT OFF PROGRAM IN
AN EFFORT TO MAKE THE EVENTS
SMALLER. SHORTER AND SMARTER
WHILE WORKING TO KEEP OUR
CUSTOMERS AND COMMUNITY SAFE
DURING TIMES OF SEVERE WEATHER.
I'M HERE TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW ARE WHILE
FAR MITIGATION PLAN AND
COMMUNITY WHILE FIRE SAFETY
PROGRAM WILL HELP REDUCE THE
THREAT OF WILDFIRES IN NORTHERN
AND CENTRAL CALIFORNIA. I'M
SURE WHAT WE ACCOMPLISHED LAST
YEAR UNDER TWENTY NINETEEN WILD
FIRE SAFETY PLAN AS WELL AS OUR
GOALS FOR THIS YEAR. UNDER THE
PLAN THAT WE SUBMITTED TO THE
CPUC LAST MONTH. I'D LIKE TO
START PROVIDING SOME CONTEXT
AROUND THE RISK SPECIFIC TO OUR
SERVICE AREA AS THE OTHER
UTILITIES DID. AS THEY DID SO.
SLIDE TO IN YOUR MATERIALS-
TALKS TO THE FIRE REX AREAS SO
THE CPU SEES COMMISSION AT THE
CPU SEES HIGH FIRE THREAT
DISTRICT MAP. HIGHLIGHTS HOW
BIG THE CHALLENGE IS FOR P.
JEANNIE. THAT MAP WAS DEVELOPED
IN COORDINATION WITH CALIFORNIA
AND BASED ON IMPACT. FROM THE
ELECTRIC UTILITIES.
COMMUNICATIONS INFRASTRUCTURE
PROVIDERS LOCAL PUBLIC SAFETY
AGENCIES. SO IT IDENTIFIES
AREAS THAT ARE HAVE ELEVATED
RISK OTHERWISE KNOWN AS TIER
TWO. AN EXTREME RISK SHOWN AS
TIER THREE. THIS MAP SHOWS HOW
DRAMATIC KLIMEK CLIMATE IMPACTS
ARE INCREASING FIRE RISK AND
IDENTIFIES AREAS IN THE STATE
WHERE THERE ARE ELEVATED AND
EXTREME RISKS OF WILDFIRES THAT
pWHEN YOU LOOK AT CALIFORNIAN
THE TOTALITY OF THE THREE I-
USE FOOT PRINTS AND HIGH FIRE
THREAT AREAS. OUR SERVICE AREA
MAKES UP SEVENTY SIX OF THE
SUIT 76% OF THE ELEVATED FIRE
RISK FOR THE TIER TWO AREAS AND
51% OF THE EXTREME FIRE RISK OR
TIER THREE AREAS. OUR SERVICE
TERRITORY IT ALSO HAS THE
LARGEST POPULATION OF OVERHEAD
CONDUCTORS- POWER LINES IN THE
HIGH FIRE THREAT AREAS. WE HAVE
OVER TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND MILES
OF OVERHEAD DISTRIBUTION LINES
WERE ABOUT 65% OF THE TOTAL I
OWE YOU OVERHEAD DISTRIBUTION
CIRCUIT MILES. IN HIGH FIRE
THREAT AREAS. MOVING ON TO THE
NEXT SLIDE. YOU CAN SEE IS THE
RESULT OF THE- OF SOME OF THE
SPECIFIC WILDFIRE RISKS THAT
OUR SERVICE TERRITORY YOU CAN
SEE THERE'S A REALLY LARGE
FORESTED FORESTED SERVICE
TERRITORY A MAJORITY OF THE
SERVICE THERE IS LOCATED IN
ELEVATED OR EXTREME FIRE RISK
AREAS AGAIN AS DEFINED BY THE
SI PC. AND WE HAVE A GREATER
NUMBER OF OVERHEAD POWER LINES.
IT'S ALSO WORTH NOTING THAT-
CALIFORNIA'S FORCE HAVE
SUFFERED GREATLY OVER THE LAST
SIX YEARS FROM HISTORIC
DROUGHT. ENTRY MORTALITY.
ACCORDING TO THE FOREST SERVICE
MORE THAN A HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN
MILLION DEAD- MILLION TREES
HAVE DIED IN OUR STATE SINCE
THE DROUGHT BEGAN IN TWENTY TEN.
MOVING ON TO SLIDE FOR OUR
TWENTY TWENTY WILD FIRE
MITIGATION PLANNED BUILDS ON
THE WORK WE COMPLETED IN TWENTY
NINETEEN I'D LIKE TO TAKE A
MINUTE TO SHARE SOME OF THE
WORK THAT WE COMPLETED IN
NINETEEN. SO WE MADE OUR
ELECTRIC SYSTEM STRONGER AND
MORE RESILIENT BY INSTALLING.
STRONGER AND MORE RESILIENT
POLLS COVERED POWER LINES ON A
HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE CIRCUIT
MILES TWENTY ONE MILES MORE
THAN OUR GOAL OF A HUNDRED
FIFTY. AND OVER THE NEXT TWELVE
TO FOURTEEN YEARS WE WILL
HARDEN SEVENTY ONE HUNDRED
MILES OF LINE AND HIGH FIRE
THREAT AREAS. WE CLEARED
VEGETATION AROUND THOUSANDS OF
MILES OF POWER LINES THROUGH
OUR ENHANCED VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT WORK WE PRUNED OR
REMOVE TREES WITH THE HIGHER
WITH THE HIGHER POTENTIAL FOR
WILDFIRE RISK. ALONG NEARLY
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED MILES OF
DISTRIBUTION LINES AND THAT
EXCEEDED THE GOAL THAT WE SET
FOR OURSELVES. WE TURNED ON A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE HIGH
DEFINITION CAMERAS FOR EARLY
SPOTTING OF WILDFIRES. AND
THAT'S THIRTY SEVEN MORE THAN
OUR GOAL WAS FOR THE YEAR. WE
INSTALLED FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY
SIX WEATHER STATIONS. EXCEEDING
OUR GOAL OF FOUR HUNDRED. WE
INSTALLED NEARLY THREE HUNDRED
SECTIONAL RISING DEVICES WHICH
I THINK WE'RE ALL RELYING ON TO
SEPARATE THE GET GRADE INTO
SMALL SECTIONS FOR OPERATIONAL
FLEXIBILITY. FINALLY IN TWENTY
NINETEEN WE ACTIVATED ONE
HUNDRED ELEVEN COMMUNITY
RESOURCE CENTERS DURING POWER
SAFETY PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT
OFF EVENTS TO PROVIDE BASIC
RESOURCES AND INFORMATION TO
OUR CUSTOMERS WE'RE GOING TO
EXPAND THAT NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY ONE THIS YEAR. MOVING
ON TO I DON'T ACTUALLY HAVE A
SLIDE FOR THE THESE TALKING
POINTS BUT- TO KEEP THE ON
POINT NOW I WILL TURN TO OUR
CONTINUED ACTIONS THIS YEAR AS
PART OF A TO MY COMMUNITY WILD
FIRE SAFETY PROGRAM TO HELP
KEEP OUR COMMUNITIES A CUSTOMER
SAFE. THESE EFFORTS ARE
DETAILED IN OUR WILD FIRE
MITIGATION PLAN WHICH CHAIR
HOLDEN REFERRED TO OUR
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN FOR REDUCING
WILDFIRE RISKS. FURTHER BUILDS
ON THE WORK THAT I JUST
DESCRIBED THAT WE COMPLETED IN
TWENTY NINETEEN SO TWENTY
NINETEEN SERVED AS A FOUNDATION
FOR TWENTY TWENTY AND THE YEARS
BEYOND. WE ARE INCLUDING NEW
GREAT TECHNOLOGY. CONTINUED
FOCUSED ON CRITICAL HARDENING
OF THE ELECTRIC SYSTEM AND THE
ENHANCED VEGETATION- OF
MANAGEMENT. A LITTLE BIT MORE
THERE WITH THAT SHORT TERM
MEDIUM TERM AND LONGER TERM-
PLANS TO MAKE OUR SISTER SAFER
OUR SYSTEM SAFE THERE. ARE
TWENTY TWENTY PLAN OUTLINES
THREE MAIN OBJECTIVES FIRST IS
REDUCING THE WILDFIRE IGNITION
POTENTIAL SECOND AS WE REDUCING
THE SPREAD POTENTIAL. AND THEN
THIRD AS REDUCING THE IMPACTS
OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT
OFFS. I YOUR MATERIAL SLIDE
FIVE. SO WE ARE REDUCING THE
RISK OF CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES
FROM ELECTRICAL COMPONENTS BY
MITIGATING THE KNOWN BECAUSE
CAUSES OF IGNITION. THROUGH OUR
ENHANCED BADGE MANAGEMENT WE
ARE MEETING AND EXCEEDING STATE
REGULATIONS FOR AND FIRE SAFETY
STANDARDS. WE'RE INSPECTING THE
VEGETATION NEAR LINES AND
PRUNING OR REMOVING OVER
APPROXIMATELY MILLION TREES TO
MAINTAIN CLEARANCE FROM OUR
POWER LINES. WE'RE CONDUCTING
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED LINE MILES OF
TWENTY AT TWELVE FOOT RADIO
CLEARANCES AND REMOVING HIGH
RISK TREES AND OVERHANGS. WE'REEXPANDING RIGHTS AWAY ON OUR
LOWER VOLTAGE TRANSMISSION
LINES TO REDUCE RISK AND FUTURE
FOR PRINCE OF PS PSP BOUNCE.
WE'RE FURTHER AUTOMATING OUR
SYSTEM BY CONTINUING TO ENABLE
DEVICES AND RE CLOSERS BUT
ALLOW OPERATORS TO REMOTELY
PREVENT A LINE FROM RE
ENERGIZING AFTER A FAULT. WE'RE
KILEY DATING PILOTING AUTOMATED
RAPID EARTH FAULT CURRENT
LIMITER TECHNOLOGY IT'S HARD TO
SAY FILL JUST SAID THAT- THAT
CAN AUTOMATICALLY REDUCE THE
ELECTRICAL CURRENT IN A DOWNED
WIRE. WERE INCORPORATED
ENHANCED INSPECTION PROCESS
SEASON TOOLS FROM OUR TWENTY
NINETEEN WILD FIRE SAFETY AND
PRO IMPROVEMENT INSPECTION
PROGRAM INTO OUR ROUTINE
INSPECTION PROGRAM. MAR
HARDENING OUR SYSTEM BY
REPLACING MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
FORTY MILES OF OVERHEAD POWER
LINES WITH STRONGER AND MORE
RESILIENT POLLS AND COVERED
POWER LINES ALONG WITH TARGETED
UNDER GROUNDING. FOR IMPROVING
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS WE'RE
IMPROVING OUR UNDERSTANDING OF
UPCOMING AND REAL TIME WEATHER
AND FIRE CONDITIONS. TO REDUCE
FIRE CONDITIONS RESPOND FASTER
AND MINIMIZE THE SCOPE OF PS PS
EVENTS. TO FURTHER ADVANCE OUR
WEATHER FORECASTING BUILD AT
CAPABILITIES WE ARE BUILDING
OUR OWN NETWORK OF WEATHER
STATIONS TO MONITOR AND
FORECAST WEATHER CONDITIONS.
BETTER PREDICT WHEN EXTREME
WILDFIRE DANGER COULD OCCUR SO
WE CAN RESPOND QUICKLY AND
APPROPRIATELY TO KEEP OUR
CUSTOMERS SAFE. WE'RE ADDING
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED NEW
WEATHER STATIONS THIS YEAR FOR
A TOTAL OF THIRTEEN HUNDRED NEW
WEATHER STATIONS BY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. AT&T THAT'S DENSITY
AS ONE STATION FOR ROUGHLY
EVERY TWENTY CIRCUIT MILES AND
THE HIGH FIRE RISK AREAS. RENTS
TOWING NEARLY TWO HUNDRED. AT
NEW HIGH DEFINITION CAMERAS IN
HIGH FIRE THREAT AREAS FOR A
TOTAL OF NEARLY SIX HUNDRED BY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AND OUR WILD
FIRE SAFETY OPERATIONS CENTER
WHICH WE ESTABLISHED IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN MONITORS POTENTIAL
WIRE FOR THREATS ACROSS OUR
SERVICE AREA IN REAL TIME. AND
COORDINATES PREVENTION AND
RESPONSE EFFORTS. IN CONCLUSION
WE'RE COMMITTED TO WORKING
TOGETHER P. JEANNIE OUR
GOVERNMENT AND ALL CALIFORNIANS
TO ADAPT- ELECTRIC SYSTEM TO
THE GROWING THREAT OF WILDFIRES.
WHILE ALSO HELPING OUR
CUSTOMERS PREPARE FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY OUTAGES WE'LL TALK MORE
ABOUT PS PS IN THE SECOND HALF.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WE DO APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENTATION THIS MORNING THIS
AFTERNOON I'M GONNA TURN TO
COMMITTEE AND OUR OUR GUESTS
MEMBERS TO SEE IF THEY HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS TO ANY OF THE
UTILITIES AT PRESENT OR MAYBE
THERE'S A QUESTION THAT APPLIES
TO ALL THREE FOR RESPONSE BUT
ALL TURN TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
IF YOU HAVE ANY. QUESTIONS AT
THIS TIME. FOR COMMENTS
DUCKWORTH. I KNOW THERE'S
CERTAINLY- CONCERNS BY EVERYONE
ABOUT THE FACT THAT THE
POWERSHOT US BUT- COMPARED TO
HAVING TO FIRE I THINK THIS IS
THE RIGHT THING I DO APPRECIATE
THAT YOU'RE GONNA BE TELLING US
ABOUT HOW YOU'RE- TRYING TO DO
THEM LESS EXPANSIVELY- SPECTRA.
I THINK IT'S JUST EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT THAT WE DON'T. THAT
EVEN THOUGH WE MAY BE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE POWER SHUT OFF THAT
YOU CONTINUE TO DO THAT- AND
NOT BE. INTIMIDATED FROM DOING
THEM WHEN IT'S THE RIGHT THING
TO REDUCE RISK I KNOW THAT. IN
THE CASES OF RPG AND I'M IN
THAT SERVICE AREA- THERE WERE A
NUMBER OF- PLACES WHERE THE
LINES HAVE BEEN G. ENERGIZED.
AND THERE ARE MANY POSSIBLE
SITES OF IGNITION SO I THINK
WAS THE RIGHT THING TO DO. AND
THEM I KNOW YOU'LL BE IMPROVING
ON YOUR TECHNIQUES AS TIME GOES
ON THANK YOU. FOR FOCUS A
LITTLE BIT MORE INTENTLY ON PSP
US IN THE NEXT SEGMENT BUT LET
ME JUST ASK A QUESTION IN TERMS
OF YOU KNOW WHEN ARE WE SAFE.
AND THIS IS A PROCESS THAT
WE'RE GOING THROUGH AN
OBVIOUSLY WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT. AT THE END OF THE DAY
THAT THE CUSTOMERS ON ONLY FILL
SAY BUT ARE. AND THE DIFFERENT
ASPECTS OF WHAT YOU'RE DOING
YOU KNOW THEY FIT INTO A- YOU
KNOW A- NEED SCHEDULE- THERE'S
A POINT. THE WHERE WE NEED TO
BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND HOW WE
ARE SAFE AND HOW WE CAN PARSE
OUT THESE DIFFERENTPIECES TO
HIT TIME FRAMES THAT- WE CAN
KIND OF RELY ON- I WAS LOOKING
AT THE CHART WHERE IT
DESCRIBES. A AND THIS IS
JEANNIE BUT I THINK ALL OF YOU
HAD REFERENCED IN YOUR YOUR
REPORT AT TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
AND RELATES TO- P. JEANNIE
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND CIRCUIT
MILES. OF P. JEANNIE SYSTEM ARE
LOCATED IN HIGH- FIRE THREAT
AREAS- AND THEN THE NEXT- SLIDE
OVER HEAD. UNDER ENHANCE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT AS AN
EXAMPLE IT DESCRIBES THE TWENTY
TWENTY TARGETED EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED MILES. LINE MILES- SO
HOW. LOOKING AT THE LONG LOOK
AT ALL OF THE YEAR THAT YOU
HAVE TO COVER IN A LOT OF TO
COVER. YOU FOR VIEWING THE LONG
TERM IN TERMS OF HOW WE CAN HOW
YOU CAN GET TO A PLACE WHERE.
YOU'RE ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE TO
THE PUBLIC WHEN YOU'RE GOING TO
GET THE TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
MILES. LINE MILES- ADDRESS SO
THAT THERE'S A SENSE OF TIMING
AND WHEN THAT TAKES PLACE AND-
HOW THAN WE CAN GET A BETTER
SENSE ON. SAFETY SO FOR I THINK
YOU KNOW RECOGNITION THAT THE
PUBLIC SAFETY POWERSHOT OF
EVENTS A REALLY IMPACTFUL TO
OUR COMMUNITIES MY FAMILY WHEN
IT WENT THROUGH A- P. S. P. S.
EVENTS AT OUR HOME. AS WELL AND
SO. TOTALLY UNDERSTAND THE
IMPACT TO THE COMMUNITIES THERE.
AS AS WAS MENTIONED EARLIER
RIGHT NOW. THAT'S WHAT PGA ANY
BELIEVES WE NEED TO DO I
BELIEVE THE OTHER INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES FEEL THE SAME
WHEN THE WEATHER CONDITIONS ARE
SUCH THAT IT'S NOT SAFE TO
LEAVE THAT THE LINES ENERGIZED
THAT WE DE ENERGIZED THEM. I
THINK WHAT EVERYBODY REALLY
WANTS TO NOW I THINK WHAT
YOU'RE GENERALLY ASKING IS-
WHEN WILL THE P. S. P. S.
EVENTS AND- HARDER TO SAY THAT
BECAUSE I THINK WE ALL BELIEVE
WE NEED TO HAVE THAT TOOL IS A
REAL LAST RESORT IN OUR IN OUR
TOOLBOX. BUT THE THINGS THAT
WE'RE DOING WITH THE VAJRAYANA
JUDGMENT. WITH THE CLEARING
AROUND THEIR SIXTY AND SEVENTY
KV LINES. WITH THE SECTION THE
LACE SEXUAL RISING DEVICES THAT
WE'RE PUTTING INTO PLACE TO
ISOLATE ONLY THE AREAS THAT ARE
GOING TO SEE. THE SIGNIFICANT
WEATHER IMPACTS ARE THINGS THAT
WE ARE DOING TO ENSURE
COMMUNITY SAFETY. YEAH IF
MILLIMETERS TO ABOUT TO FIND A
POINT IN TERMS OF THE DATES- IN
TERMS OF HOW TO COME UP WITH
THE DATES FOR COMPLETION OF THE
WORK THAT. ADDRESSES THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE COVERAGE THE
LINES WHICH AND HOW YOU CAN GET
TO THAT PONT SO THAT THE
PUBLIC KNOWS WHEN YOU WILL HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED OF BASED ON TIME
FRAMES THE GOAL OF SAFETY AND
LINE SECURITY. SO IT'S A GOOD
QUESTION THIS IS UNDER FROM
EACH ANY AND IT'S GOOD SO THAT
WE TALKED A LOT BECAUSE THIS IS
THE TO RIGHT YOU WE HAVE THIS
MAP THAT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT AND
WHAT THOSE LINE MILES ARE WE
THE CLAIM IS CONTINUING TO
CHANGE AND THAT WILL CONTINUE
TO EVOLVE. AND SO WE ARE BEING
CONDITIONS WILL CONTINUE TO
EVOLVE IN THE EXAMPLE OF
ENHANCE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
WE- LAID OUT IN OUR REGULAR OUR
GENERAL RATE CASE THAT WE HAD A
TEN YEAR PLAN TO GET TO ALL OF
THE MILES WITH THIS ENHANCE%
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
TREATMENT. BUT WE'RE STARTING
WE USE A LOT OF- MODELS TO
IDENTIFY WHERE THE HIGHEST RISK
AREAS ARE SO IT'S NOT AN EVEN
PACE IN TERMS OF RISK REDUCTION
WE'RE STARTING IN THE AREAS
THAT HAVE THE MOST BANG FOR OUR
BUCK IN TERMS OF TREATING THE
VEGETATION AND REMOVING RISK.
SAME THING ON OUR SYSTEM
HARDENING- PROGRAM WHERE WERE
HARDENING THE LINES ARE PUTTING
THEM UNDERGROUND AND SO- THOSE
ARE LONG TERM PROGRAMS RIGHT
TEN YEARS TO DO ALL THE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT IS NOT AS
FAST AS WE WOULD ALL LIKE IT TO
BE. BUT WE'RE USING THE BEST
DATA WE HAVE AVAILABLE TO US TO
IDENTIFY THE AREAS MOST AT RISK
OF AN IGNITION AND MOST AT RISK
OF A CATASTROPHIC SPREAD SO
THAT WE CAN- AND IMPROVE SAFETY
THE FACT IS. IF THE RESOURCES
AND- THE BILL IT IS PART. WITH
THESE LARGE SCALE PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU EXCEPT MAYBE THE ONLY
THING SO COME THINGS WILL LIKE
TO HAVE THE CON UP. THAT IS A
WE'RE ALL WORKING AS HARD AS WE
CAN FIND AN ANSWER TO I THERE'S
A FEW THINGS WE ARE DEALING
WITH A HIGH ENERGY SYSTEM I
THINK EVERYBODY REALIZES THAT
SO GETTING TO ZERO- I THINK IS-
THAT THAT'S THAT'S A LOOSE OF-
IN OUR BENCHMARKING WITH
OVERSEAS UTILITIES- THEY
PROJECTED. AFTER SEVERAL YEARS
OF HARDENING UP STILL SEEING
NATION'S OTHER SYSTEM I THINK
WHAT'S IMPORTANT THOUGH IS THAT
WE LOOK AT THIS FROMA RISK
STANDPOINT AND IT'S WHAT WE'RE
DOING. WE HAVE IN OUR
DISTRIBUTION NETWORK IN HIGH
FAR RISKIER IS ROUGHLY TEN
THOUSAND CIRCUIT MILES. BY THE
END OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE-
WILL OF COVERED AROUND SIX
THOUSAND OF THOSE MILES SO
PRETTY RAPID- RAPID COVERING AT
THAT INFRASTRUCTURE- BUT MUCH
AS MATT SAID- WE'RE NOT DOING
THIS IN A- I'D SAY PANCAKE
FASHION OR BEING ABOUT FACTION
BUT WE'RE DOING IS HIGHLIGHTED
WHAT IS THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
AREAS IT FIRST. AND FRANKLY
THOSE WE'VE ACTUALLY COVERED
ALREADY SO THAT SITTING THE
THREAT OF EMISSIONS AND ALSO
HITTING THE CONSEQUENCE SIDE OF
IT RIGHT AWAY- THERE ARE OTHER
VARIABLES I THINK THE LATEST
OUR THE UTILITY BECAUSE- OR YOU
TO. AROUND 10% WHILE FIVE SO
THAT ANOTHER FACTOR. WHAT WE
ALL THE SCENE AND I THINK WHAT
WE CAN TO LEAVE IT SHARE THE
WITH WITH THE SAN IS. MANY
PIECES TO UTILITY IN. DRIVING
THOSE TWO ZERO QUICK AS WE CAN
AND USING OUR TARP COLLUDED
THAT HARDING PS S. OPERATION
PRACTICE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT.
FOCUSED THE THINGS WE CAN GET
AWAY OF BUDGET TO MANAGE IT
PAYS OFF REAL REAL QUICK YOU
CAN TURN YOUR WHOLE SYSTEM IN A
YEAR AND YOU'VE GOT THE BENEFIT
BUT ALSO CONTINUE TO INVEST IN
FIVE A RESPONSE KEEP WE'VE SEEN
THAT VERY. AND THE OF REACTIONS
PURCHASED CAN PLAY A BIG ROLE
IN ALL MITIGATING AND GET A
ARGUE CENTER IF YOU SAFE AS
WELL. I JUST WANT TO- GO BACK
TO THE CHAIRS QUESTION BECAUSE
I THINK THAT IS. ULTIMATELY THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING. THAT WERE
RESPONSIBLE FOR WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO TELL THE CUSTOMERS.
THAT YOU CAN NEXT YOU CAN
EXPECT THAT THIS IS A TIME
LINE. YOU'RE RIGHT IT'S NEVER
GOING TO BE ZERO. BUT WE HAVE
TO HAVE A PLAN TO. GET TWO ZERO
AND GET AS CLOSE TO THAT AS
POSSIBLE SO. THAT ULTIMATELY IS
THE MOST IMPORTANT QUESTION IS.
WHAT WAS YOUR QUESTION AGAIN.
IS WHEN WE SAY. IT IS WHEN WE
SAY WHAT DO WHAT DO WE- WHAT IS
A TIME LINE SO THAT WE CAN TELL
ARE THE CUSTOMERS. BY THIS TIME
WE EXPECT YOU TO BE SAFE.
NOBODY FEEL SAFE RIGHT NOW. I
I'D I THINK THAT'S A- THAT
THAT'S SOMETHING WE'RE ALL
WORKING TOWARDS- AND I THINK
THIS IS A IS A KEY QUESTION. ON
A BRING MAYBE TO THE FOR OUR
TWENTY TWENTY WHILE FIRE
MITIGATION PLANS AND- AS YOU
LOOK TO THOSE- ONE OF THINGS
WE'VE BEEN ASKED TO DO IS
FORECAST TO DECLINE IN THE
NATION'S. NOW IT'S A RELATIVELY
STRAIGHTFORWARD A WAY OF
APPROACHING IT BUT- BUT LOOKING
AT HOW WE'RE PERFORMING IN THE
END OF THE ANALYSIS WE NEED TO
SEE THAT EVERYTHING WE'RE DOING
IS ACTUALLY RESULTING IN FEWER
EMISSIONS. AND LOWER
CONSEQUENCE WHEN THERE ARE
NATIONS- AS WE LOOK TO THESE
PLANS AND AS I LOOK AT OUR
PLANS WE ARE IN A MUCH BETTER
PLACE THAN WE WERE LAST YEAR.
WE WILL BE IN A MUCH MUCH
BETTER PLACE NEXT YEAR AS WE
CONTINUE TO DEPLOY THESE
MEDICATIONS AND THAT'S THE PATH
AND THAT'S THE JOURNEY WERE ON.
WHAT WE DON'T HAVE A DATE OR WE
CAN SAY IT'S SAFE BECAUSE I
THINK THERE'S SO MANY VARIABLES
AND WE'RE INVESTING AND ART AND
ART TIME. AND OUR AND OUR
EFFORTS IN MAKING SURE WE GET
THERE AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE-
WE HAVE TO GET THROUGH ANOTHER
WILDFIRE SEASON I THINK WE CAN
LOOK AT OUR SYSTEM NOW AND SAY.
IT IS MUCH SAFER THAN IT WAS
LAST YEAR AND WE'RE ONNA
CONTINUE IMPROVE ON THAT- AND
THAT PROGRESS. THANK YOU. WHAT
THANK THANK YOU AND THIS IS
JUST A GENERAL QUESTION WHY
SHOULD PRIME MORE DIRECTED
TOWARD EACH UNIQUE SAYS MY
SERVICE SURGERY SO- HOW HOW ARE
YOU PRIORITIZING ARE YOU ARE
YOU PRIORITIZING THE HIGHEST
RISK AREAS AND IT RELATIVE TO
SEE PUBLIC SAFETY- HOW ARE YOU
HOW ARE YOU PART WHICH ISING
ARE USING ARE USING FOR EXAMPLE
WE'VE I'M AWARE OF THE COMPANY
CALLED TECHNO SOBRE USING
INFORMATION FROM TECHNO SILVA
OR ARE YOU ARE SO WE ARE WE ARE
FOR- FOR PRIDE PRIORITIZING BY
OUR WILD FIRE RISK AREAS BY THE
POPULATIONS WITHIN THOSE WILD
FIRE RISK AREAS WE'RE
INCORPORATING AS YOU MENTIONED
THE TECHNO SILVA TECHNOLOGY.
INTO OUR METEOROLOGY FOR OF
CASTLE IT'S NOT JUST WHAT'S THE
WEATHER IMPACTS THAT ARE COMING
IN BUT ALSO WHAT IS THE
POTENTIAL FOR THE WILDFIRE
SPREAD THAT CAN OCCUR WITH THAT
AND THAT'S THE TECHNO SILVA
PEACE. SO WE'RE WE'RE TAKING
ALL OF THOSE PIECES WITH A RISK
BASED VIEW. TO UNDERSTAND WHERE
WE SHOULD BE APPLYING. OUR
MEDICATIONS. SO ARE YOU- AND I
GUESS AND IS THE FOLLOW UP TO
THAT AND THAT'S THE- YOU'RE
CREATING- THESE SWITCHING
DEVICES OR SORT SECTION. I'M
QUITE A MEMBER EXACT TERM USED.
AND THE SECTIONAL I THINK THIS
ACTUALIZING SO. TO BE ABLE TO
REALLY DRILL DOWN AND CUT OFF
ONLY THOSE AREAS IT ABSOLUTELY
NEED THAT. SO I THOUGHT THAT
TECHNOLOGY EGGS EXISTED ALREADY
SO I'M KIND OF SURPRISED THAT
WERE IN TWENTY TWENTY AND- WE
CAN'T REALLY SECTION ALLIES THE
GRID LIKE THAT SO- IS THAT THE
SAME AND THE OTHER TWO. UTILITY
ATLANTIC I SAW ALL SPEAK RIGHT
HERE IT REALLY TAKES THE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE
ENVIRONMENT THE WEATHER. IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE SWITCHING
DEVICE THAT ALLOWS YOU TO BE
THAT PRECISE SO YOU- BY
INSTALLING THE WEATHER STATIONS
EARLY IN GETTING THE TEN YEAR
HISTORY THAT WE HAVE. WE
UNDERSTAND THIS SMALL SEGMENT
THAT AFFECTS YOU KNOW JUST THIS
HUNDRED CUSTOMERS WHAT THE
WEATHER ENVIRONMENT IN
CONDITIONS ARE THERE AND THEN.
ONCE WE GET INTO AN OPERATIONAL
SITUATION WE LOOK AT THE
CONDITIONS AND ARE ABLE TO MAKE
A REAL TIME DECISION AND OPEN
THAT SECTION LIES IN THE VICE
THAT'S ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
WEATHER STATION. THUS ISOLATING
THAT AREA. YOU HAVE A TEN YEAR
HISTORY YOU DON'T SO HOW IS
THIS GOING TO MAKE US SAFER AND
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS. SO FIRST
WE'VE BEEN BENCHMARKING WITH
BOTH OF THE OTHER UTILITIES AND
STEALING SHAMELESS FROM BOTH OF
THEM TELL YOU THAT WE'RE
WORKING TO MAKE OUR- OUR
EVENTS. SMARTER SHORTER AND
IS. IN THE WEATHER FORECASTING
AND THE TECHNO SILVA
TECHNOLOGIES SO WE'RE TAKING
OUR WEATHER FORECAST IF YOU
IMAGINE OUR SERVICE TERRITORY
SEVENTY THOUSAND SQUARE MILES.
AND YOU YOU BREAK IT DOWN AND
THE PIXELS. LAST YEAR OUR
CAPABILITY WAS TO FORECAST
WEATHER IN THREE COLLAMER BY
THREE KILOMETER PIXELS. THIS
YEAR WE'RE REDUCING THAT WE'RE
SHRINKING THAT TO BUY TEN
CLIMBERS SO- OUR WEATHER
FORECASTING COMBINED WITH THE
WILDFIRE SPREAD IS GOING TO
GIVE US MUCH BETTER-
UNDERSTANDING OF WHERE THE AND
WHETHER IMPACTS WILL HIT. THEN
WITH THE ADDITIONAL SECTIONAL
ISING DEVICES WE ARE ABLE TO
ONLY ISOLATE THE FOLKS WHO ARE
IN THE AREA OF THE SEVERE
WEATHER SO THAT'S GONNA MAKE
THE EVENTS MUCH SMALLER THEN-
WE'RE WE'VE BROUGHT ON
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES WE HAVE
CONTRACTED HELICOPTERS WERE
NEARLY DOUBLING OUR HELICOPTER
RESOURCES TO FLY THE LINES TO
ENSURE THERE'S NO DEBRIS IN
THEM. BEFORE WE RE ENERGIZE
THOSE LINES WERE ALSO BRINGING
IN SOME FIXED WING AIRCRAFT TO
BE ABLE TO PERFORM NIGHT
PATROLS FOR OUR TRANSMISSION
LINES SO THAT WE CAN RESTORE
CUSTOMERS EVEN FASTER AND WE'RE
LOOKING TO MOVE THOSE RIGHT
RESTORATION TIMES FROM TWENTY
FOUR HOURS AFTER THE WIND EVENT
ENDS TO TWELVE HOURS. DAHLE
YOU'D LIKE THAT I MENTIONED
EARLIER IN THE DISCUSSION OF
OUR INVESTMENT TRAJECTORY OVER
THE LAST. DECADE OR SO OF
ELEVEN BILLION DOLLARS. A BIG
PART OF THAT WAS THE SECTIONAL
RISING WAS PART OF OUR GREAT
MODERNIZATION PROGRAM- THEY ON
AVERAGE WE HAVE FOUR DEVICES
SECTION LIGHTING DEVICES- PER
CIRCUIT- SO THAT'S SOMETHING
WE'RE EXPLOITING EVEN MORE NOW
WE DIDN'T LAST WILDFIRE SEASON
LAST PSP IS EVENT- SEASON. ONE
OF THESE WERE ALSO BUILDING
INTO THE PROGRAM AND IT WILL
PROBABLY COME UP A LITTLE BIT
LATER DURING THE PS PS
DISCUSSION. UP IS ACTUALLY
BUILDING EFFECTIVELY AND WHAT
IS A PLAYBOOK FOR EVERY SINGLE
CIRCUIT SO WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
YOU GET IN THESE EVENTS YOU
DON'T KNOW WHERE THEY'RE COMING
FROM YOU MAY HAVE- NGUYEN FROM
ONE DIRECTION TO ANOTHER
DIRECTION A CERTAIN. PORTION OF
THE CIRCUIT- RECEIVING THE HIGH
WINDS ANOTHER BUT PORTION NOT
SO OR DOING FOR BREAKING EACH
ONE DOWN SAYING IN THIS
SITUATION. THIS IS HOW YOU
SEXUAL LIFE THE CIRCUIT SO.
INSTEAD OF IN THE EVENT.
ASSESSING THE SITUATION AND
COMING UP WITHA PLAN WE'RE
GONNA MULTIPLE PLANS GOING INTO
THE SCENARIO SO WE CAN SECTION
LIES MUCH MORE EFFECTIVELY AND
WE SEE THAT THAT MAKES A HUGE
DIFFERENCE- IT'S- IT'S UP TO
HALF THE NUMBER OF CUSTOMERS ON
ANY GIVEN CIRCUIT. OR MORE TO
BANG ON HOW MUCH. HOW MUCH
YOU'RE ABLE TO- TO PARSE THAT
OUT IN BIG EVENTS CANDIDLY BIG
EVENTS TAKE. MY MORE OF THE
CIRCUIT WITHIN THEM SO. REDUCE
OPPORTUNITY FOR TWICE BUT THAT
WOULD. OKAY THIS MESSAGE. THANK
YOU I WANTED TO FOLLOW UP
MISTER WOULD SAY QUESTION TO P.
JEANNIE AND ADDISON WITH SIR
MIGHT ADD HOW DO YOU PRIORITIZE
TH WILD FIRE MITIGATION
INVESTMENTS AB SO- A VERY VERY
SIMILAR STORY- WE'RE USING A
KIND OF A PRECURSOR TO TECHNO
SILVA WE WILL BE WITH ACT OF
CIVIL AS WELL CALL REACTS- IT
ASSESSES A NUMBER OF DIMENSIONS
INCLUDING POPULATION
STRUCTURES- PROPENSITY TO
SPREAD WHAT HAPPENS WHEN IT
DOES SPREAD. THEN WE MARRY THAT
UP WITH SOMETHING THAT WE'VE
DONE BILL TO THE MACHINE
LEARNING CAPABILITY LURKING
LOOKING AT ALL OF OUR DEVICES
AND PIECES OF EQUIPMENT SO WHAT
WE DO IS WE COMBINE A
PROBABILITY OF FAILURE WITH THE
CONSEQUENCE OF THAT FAILURE AND
WE GET A SCORE AND WE LOOK AT
THAT AND BY THE WAY THIS IS ONE
OF DIMENSIONS WE USE WE'RE ALSO
LOOKING AT HOW OFTEN WAS A
CUSTOMER IMPACTED BY P. S. P.
S. IS THE MATH IS GREAT IT
HELPS US. BUT WE HAVE TO BRING
SOME COMMON SENSE OF THESE
DECISIONS AS WELL SO WE'RE
MARRYING I'D SAY COMPLEX
ANALYTIC TOOLS WITH COMMON AN
OPERATING HISTORY. TO
PRIORITIZE OUR INVESTMENTS OVER
TIME. ALL RIGHT. I'D LIKE TO A
GOD TURNED TO P. GINNY AND ASK
YOU A COUPLE QUESTIONS RELATED
TO. THE WILD FIRE SAFETY
MITIGATION- INVESTMENTS FIRST
OF ALL I I'M NOT TO. FAMILIAR
WITH HOW. YOU ACCOUNT FOR THE
REVENUES THAT ARE COLLECTED
FROM RATE PAYERS SPECIFICALLY
FOR WILD FIRE MITIGATION
INVESTMENTS EIGHT DO YOU HAVE A
SEPARATE ACCOUNTING CAN YOU
POINT LIKE ON A SPREADSHEET TO
HOW MUCH- REVENUES ARE
COLLECTED FROM P. JEANNIE RATE
PAYERS FOR WHAT FAR MITIGATION
ON VESTMENTS. SO BUT NOT
REALLY- AS PART OF OUR-
REGULATORY SCHEME WE HAVE RATE
CASES ARE GENERAL RATE CASE THE
BULK OF OUR WILDFIRE PROGRAMS
HAVE BEEN REFLECTED OUR GENERAL
RATE CASE. THAT AGGREGATES UP A
REVENUE RICARDO REQUIREMENT
THAT TURNS INTO- RATES SO WE
CAN WE HAVE OF COURSE SEPARATE
ACCOUNTING SO WE KNOW WHAT WE
SPENT ON DIFFERENT ACTIVITIES
INCLUDING A WILDFIRE
ACTIVITIES- BUT AND SO THERE'S
WAYS TO ESTIMATE. HOW MUCH OF
OUR RATES THAT MIGHT BE OR A
PERCENTAGE BUT IT'S NOT A
DIRECT ONE FOR ONE OKAY SO IN
OTHER WORDS- WHEN THE CONCERN
WAS RAISED EARLIER ABOUT. ALVY
WHAT FOR MITIGATION INVESTMENTS
ARE LIKELY TO LEAD TO HIGHER
ON- RATES FOR CUSTOMERS.
THERE'S NO WAY TO. BREAK DOWN
AND WHAT. PORTION OF THE HIGHER
RATES ARE GOING TOWARD WILD
FIRE MITIGATION INVESTMENTS.
NOT DIRECTLY THERE'D RULES OF
THUMB AND SORT OF A PERCENTAGE
ESTIMATIONS YOU CAN MAKE BUT
DOES NOT. STRAIGHT FORWARD OKAY
ARM IN TERMS OF THE. OKAY SO-
SO BECAUSE THERE'S NO
ACCOUNTING FOR AND THERE IS NO
OVERSIGHT FROM THE PC IN TERMS
OF. THE AMOUNT OF REVENUES WHAT
WHAT YOU KNOW WHAT REVENUES-
COLLECTED FROM RATE PAYERS ARE
GOING TOWARD WHAT FIRED
PERCENTAGES AT AS YOU JUST
INDICATED AMENDED WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT GENERAL
PERCENTAGE ESTIMATES SO- IN
THIS SPACE THE CPUC REGULATES
OUR MANAGES US ON WHAT WE SPEND
RIGHT SO THE REVENUE SIDE IS-
SOMEWHAT. DISCONNECTED BUT OUR
TWENTY TWENTY GENERAL RATE CASE
WHICH IS BEING- MANAGED THROUGH
THE CPC RIGHT NOW IT'S AN OPEN
PROCEEDING HAS SPECIFIC
ACCOUNTS WITH SPECIFIC CAPS
ASSOCIATE WITH WILD FIRE
ACTIVITIES SO FAR VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM THERE'S A
CERTAIN PROPOSED CAP AND IF WE
HAVE TO SPEND MORE THAN THAT
THERE'S- A IT KICKS IN
ADDITIONAL REVIEW PROCESS SEES.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE WERE
SPENDING IT PRUDENTLY AND
THINGS OF THAT NATURE SO BALL
FOR VEGETATION MANAGEMENT AS
WELL AS THE SYSTEM HARDENING
ASSET PROGRAMS WE HAVE SPECIAL
ACCOUNTING SET UP SO NOT SO
MUCH ON THE REVENUE SIDE BUT ON
THE SPENDING SIDE ARE WE
SPENDING PRUDENTLY THERE ARE
VARIOUS AND MULTIPLE-
REGULATORY PROCESSES TO SUPPORT
THAT. HOW DIFFICULT WOULD IT BE
FOR THE- FOR THE PC TO- REQUIRE.
PGA TO BREAK DOWN THE- OUR
ACTUAL REVENUES- FROM RATE
PAYERS THAT ARE BEING USED FOR
WHAT FIRE- MITIGATION
INVESTMENTS I'M SURE THAT THERE
AN ANALYSIS COULD BE PERFORMED
TO GET A GOOD ESTIMATE THAT.
ARI BUT AS OF NOW IN TERMS OF
THE PC OVERSIGHT. IT IS
PRIMARILY FOCUSED ON THE
EXPENDITURE SIDE AND NOT AND IN
TERMS OF THE REVENUES COLLECTED
FOR RATEPAYERS AND THE
PERCENTAGES I GO TOWARD ONE FAR
MEDICATION INVESTMENTS. WHEN I
WOULD ADD TO THAT CONVERSATION
IS THAT THE WILD FIRE
MITIGATION PLAN IN THE
PRECEDING THAT WE HAVE BEFORE
THE CPUC AS AROUND THE ADEQUACY
OF THE MEASURES. THAT WE'RE
PUTTING INTO OUR PLANS IN ORDER
TO ADDRESS THE WILD FIRE
MITIGATION IT'S REALLY THE
FOCUS IS NOT ON THE FENCE
FINANCIALS BUT IS ON THE
ACTIONS IN THE ACTIVITIES THAT
THAT UTILITIES ARE UNDERTAKEN.
I YEAH I JUST WANT TO. YOU KNOW
FLAG. WE HAD A- OUR OUR LAST
HEARING WAS ON- THE RISING
ELECTRICITY RATES AND SO WELL
AS- YOU'RE TELLING US TO
EXPECT- EVEN HIGHER RATES WITH
THE WITH THE GREATER- AND NEED
TO. INCREASE WATER MITIGATION
INVESTMENTS IN A WORK AYE. I
THINK FOR THE SAKE OF A
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
WELL. WE MAY WANT TO EXPLORE.
MEASURES THAT- OR OR STEPS THAT
THE PC CAN CAN TAKE AS WELL AS
WITH THE LEGISLATURE CAN DO TO
BE ABLE TO- SHOW RATE PAYERS
LIKE WHY. THE RATES ARE GOING
HIGHER AND HOW MUCH OF THAT IS
DUE TO THE WATER FOR MEDICATION
INVESTMENTS RIGHT RIGHT I THINK
THAT'S A I THINK THAT'S- JUST
IN THE AIR MARY OF TRANSPARENCY
WE WOULD AGREE WITH THAT AYE
AYE THERE IS JUST TO BE CLEAR-
MANY PLACES WHERE WE ARE-
BEING- MAY HAVE CHECKED. YOUR
OR WORK WITH THE CBC TO ENSURE
THAT WHAT WE'RE SPENDING IS
PRUDENT- EVEN THOUGH PURSUANT
TO OFFER MITIGATION PLANS WILL
BE SUBJECT. AUDITS AND REVIEWS
OF THE WORK WE DID TO ENSURE
WAS A COMPLETE- WE DID WE DID
WE SPEND THE RIGHT AMOUNT OF
MONEY ASSOCIATED WITH IT. A TO
THE EXTENT THAT THAT FLOWS TO
THE REVENUE SIDE BOB THAT'S DID
THERE SHOULD BE A CLEAR TRAIL
FOR ALL THAT OKAY. I THANK.
IT'S BEEN POINTED OUT TO ME
THAT A LOT OF WHAT YOU WERE
JUST DESCRIBING IS IN YOUR
REPORT. THE CENTER EDISON. BUT
I THINK. THIS THAT ARE THAT ARE
OUT IN TERMS OF WHAT I THINK-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WAS ASKING
PHOTOS OF THE BROADCAST AREAS
THAT THAT'S THAT WOULD BE OUR
THREE POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS OF CAPITAL INVESTMENT
PLUS THE ANA. KATA BEFORE WE
TRANSITION TO THE THIRD SEGMENT
OF THIS HEARING- I JUST WANT TO
KIND OF GO BACK TO THE QUESTION
THAT WAS REYES WAS FOLLOWING UP
ON AND REALLY TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND. THAT THE ANSWER WAS
AND CONFLATING SORT OF THE
EXPECTATION OF MEETING. OUR
STATE STATUTE. OF CPUC RULES
VERSES ENHANCED WORK. ANY KIND
OF THE ENHANCED WORK. IS WERE
THE REFERENCE I THINK WAS FOR
TEN YEARS AND THAT THAT WAS HOW
YOU'RE LOOKING AT. BUT MAYBE
YOU CAN BREAK THOSE OUT AND
GIVE US A CLEAR UNDERSTANDING
OF HOW YOU'RE COMPLYING WITH
THE STATUTE AND WITH RULES OF
THE CPUC. SEPARATELY FROM- YOUR
ENHANCED- WORK AROUND
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT AND SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT YOU'RE- ALSO
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH UNDER
THIS- YOUR WELFARE MITIGATION
PLAN. SO ARE THE- ROUTINE
OPERATIONS- ARE IN COMPLIANCE
WITH ALL OF REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS FOR EXAMPLE THERE
WAS A CHANGE IN THE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT RULES AT THE
BEGINNING OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE
HAD. THINK AN EIGHTEEN MONTH
WORKING PERIOD TO EXPAND THE
CLEARANCE IN CERTAIN AREAS OF
OUR SERVICE TERRITORY AND SO WE
IMMEDIATELY ADJUSTED OUR
PROCESSES TO ACCOMMODATE THAT
NEW REQUIREMENT SO OUR ROUTINE
OPERATIONS ARE IN LINE WITH-
THE COMPLIANCE REGULATIONS AND
EXPECTATIONS. LARGELY FROM THE
CPC SOME FROM STATE CODE SOME
EVEN FROM FEDERAL REGULATION.
PRETTY MUCH EVERYTHING IN OUR
WELFARE MITIGATION PLAN IS
ABOVE AND BEYOND THE COMPLIANCE
MINIMUMS RIGHT SO COVERED
CONDUCTOR IS NOT A REQUIRED.
YOU KNOW CONSTRUCTION MODEL BUT
IT'S A PRUDENT ACTIVITY TO
UNDERTAKE TO REDUCE THE WILD
FIRE RISK SO WE TALK ABOUT TEN
YEARS FOR ENHANCE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT SEVENTY ONE HUNDRED
MILES OF COVERED CONDUCTOR.
THOSE ARE ALL ABOVE AND BEYOND
THE COMPLIANCE MEETING STATE
MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS- SO I HOPE
THAT ANSWERS THE QUESTION THE
WAY YOU'RE THINKING. THANK YOU
WE'RE WE'RE GONNA TRANSITION
NOW- SOME OF WHAT OBVIOUSLY IS-
MAJOR PART OF THE CONVERSATION
IS UNDER THE SPS BECAUSE WE HAD
AN OPPORTUNITY TO EXPERIENCE IT
AT THE END OF LAST YEAR. AND
THERE IT HAD RAISED A LOT OF
QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS AND I
THINK THAT BETWEEN. THAT TIME
AND NOW IT GIVES- YOUR YOUR
PLAN SORT OF ADDRESSES HOW THE
INTERNALIZATION IS GOING TO
WORK BUT ALSO MAYBE JUST
REFLECT ON. WHAT HAPPENED AT
THE END OF LAST YEAR WHERE
YOU'RE SERVICE TERRITORIES WERE
IMPACTED AND I KNOW MEMBERS
AROUND THE DíAS CERTAINLY WERE
LIVING IN REAL TIME. HOW YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT GOING FORWARD
AND WE'LL MAYBE LESSONS LEARNED
THROUGH THAT PROCESS AND AS WAS
POINTED OUT EARLIER WHEN THE
SUPERINTENDENT WAS HERE WHAT.
IMPACT YOU SEE THAT MIGHT- FALL
UPON SCHOOLS AND WHAT YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT IN TERMS OF
DRESSING ISSUES OF SCHOOLS
THROUGHOUT THE- STATE. OKAY AND
SINCE WE DON'T HAVE TO CHANGE
ANYONE WOULD JUST GO RIGHT BACK
TO THE- ALL RIGHT I WOULD NEED
OFF THE AGAIN- JOHN JENKINS OF
SAN DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC VICE
PRESIDENT ELECTRIC SYSTEM
OPERATIONS AND- I'M GOING TO
BE- REVIEWING- OF AT A HIGH
LEVEL THE EVENTS OF THIS PAST
FALL THE LESSONS LEARNED AND
THEN. WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
IMPROVEMENTS- FROM THOSE
LESSONS LEARNED HEADING INTO
TWENTY TWENTY SO THE FIRST
SLIDE IS JUST COVERING OF. THE
RESULTS OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFF EVENTS FROM- TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. A WE HAD
FIVE RED FLAG WARNING EVENTS
OCTOBER NOVEMBER- WE- HAD- PS
PS IN AND FOUR OF THEM WANT ONE
OF THEM WAS NINETEEN CUSTOMERS
SO THAT'S NOT LISTED ON HERE-
RHYTHM TO SPEND THE BULK OF THE
TIME JUST TALKING ABOUT THE
OCTOBER THIRTIETH AND THIRTY
FIRST EVENT WHICH WAS. A TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
CUSTOMERS THAT WERE ULTIMATELY-
SHUT OFF FOR A PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFF- AND THIS MAY
GET TO A MEMBER WOODS-
CONVERSATION JUST UNDERSTAND
HOW WE DO THIS. SO IT WASN'T
THE TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED CUSTOMERS ALL AT ONCE
BASED ON A FORECAST WE- WE SENT
OUT A NOTIFICATION TO ROUGHLY
FORTY THOUSAND CUSTOMERS THAT
THEY MAY EXPERIENCE A PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF- THEN AS
WE GET INTO REAL TIME- WE
MONITOR THE EVENTS CLOSELY.
STATION BY STATION. LOOK AT THE
WEATHER EVENTS FROM THAT
WEATHER STATION AS SOON AS THEY
GET ABOVE A THRESHOLD REFILL
THE RISK IS TOO GREAT TO LEAVE
THE INFRASTRUCTURE ENERGIZED-
WE MAKE A DECISION TO SHUT OFF
THAT PARTICULAR SEGMENT SO
THERE WERE EIGHTY FOUR SEPARATE
DECISIONS. AT DIFFERENT TIMES-
THAT AVERAGES AROUND THREE IN
AND FOR CUSTOMERS A DECISION.
TO ULTIMATELY GET TO THAT
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED AND THAT'S- THAT'S A
WAY FOR US TO ONLY IMPACT THE
CUSTOMERS THAT NEED TO BE
IMPACTED ALSO IT'S A WAY FOR US
TO. MAKE SURE WE'RE DOING IT IN
A SHORT OF ADORATION AS
POSSIBLE. AND JUST THE SAME AS
WE DE ENERGIZED THEN WE USE THE
SAME FORECAST IN AND-
INFORMATION TO IDENTIFY AT WHAT
TIME PERIODS IT'LL BE SAFE TO
RE ENERGIZE THEM- WE HAVE. THE
PRE SCRIPTED US WHICH PLANS AND
BOOKS WE KNOW WHAT AREAS NEED
TO BE PATROLLED BY HELICOPTER
WE WENT WE KNOW WHICH AREAS CAN
BE PATROLLED BY FOOT- WE
REQUIRE A FULL PATROL- BEFORE
WE RE ENERGIZE SOMETHING WE
ALSO HAVE CONTRACT FIREFIGHTING
RESOURCES IN THE AREA- JUST IN
THE EVENT. THAT THAT SOMETHING
WERE TO HAPPEN- AND- SO THAT'S
WHAT LIMITS ARE- DURATION TO AN
AVERAGE CUSTOMER TWENTY FOUR
HOURS AND IN THAT EVENT AD
THEN THE LONGEST CUSTOMER FOR
THAT EVENT WAS WAS THIRTY THREE
HOURS. THE PEAK WINDS FOR THAT
EVENT WERE SIXTY EIGHT MILES AN
HOUR AT ARE STILL HILL WEATHER
STATION. WE DEPLOYED SEVEN
COMMUNITY RESOURCE CENTERS
WHERE WE PROVIDE- ICE WATER
PLACES FOR PEOPLE TO CHARGE OUR
PHONES TO GET INFORMATION ABOUT
THE EVENT- THOSE SORTS OF
THINGS INTO COMMUNITY
INFORMATION. CENTERS ALONG WITH
THAT- I SHOULD'VE SAID IT'S A
SHOULD BE A SUCCESSFUL PATROL
WE DID FIND TEN DAMAGE
LOCATIONS WHERE WE NEEDED TO
REMOVE A TREE BRANCH OR OR FIX
SOMETHING ON WHENEVER. OVERHEAD
POLLS- PRIOR TO RE ENERGIZING
THAT SO- AND THAT'S NOT EVEN
CAPTURING EVERYTHING THAT COULD
HAPPEN YOU CAN HAVE A TREAT.
THE FULL CROSS THE LINE BUT
ULTIMATELY FELL IN CLEAR ITSELF
AND YOU YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT OF
WHAT HAPPENED AFTER THE PATROL.
MORE WIRE SLAPPING TOGETHER
DURING THE EVENT- SO BUT TEN
THINGS WE KNEW- THAT HAPPENED
THAT NEED TO BE RECTIFIED
BEFORE WE CAN RE ENERGISE THE-
THE INFRASTRUCTURE SAFELY. AND
THEN THE LESSONS FROM A MAN- WE
ARE CALM CONSTANTLY TRYING TO
CONTINUOUSLY IMPROVE AS WE GO
THROUGH THESE EVENTS TO LEARN
ABOUT THE INFORMATION ABOUT OUR
SYSTEM BUT ALSO WHAT WE CAN DO
TO HELP OUR CUSTOMERS- WE HOLD-
TOWN HALLS AND ALL THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WERE AFFECTED
AFTER THE EVENT- I'VE ATTENDED
THESE MYSELF WHILE WE LISTEN TO
THE CUSTOMERS- IDENTIFY
CONCERNS AND THINGS THAT WE CAN
DO BETTER WAYS IN WHICH WE CANCOMMUNICATE BETTER- WE HAD
NINE. OPEN HOUSES AND SAFETY
FAIRS THIS PAST SUMMER WERE WE
COORDINATE WITH. OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS AND COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS- I WENT TO
THE ONE IN ALPINE WHICH IS ONE
OF OUR BACK COUNTRY
COMMUNITIES- THERE WERE FIVE
HUNDRED PEOPLE THERE WITH
THIRTY SIX BOOTHS WITH AMERICAN
RED CROSS. FIRST RESPONDERS%
OBVIOUSLY IN AN S. T. GINNY
PRESENCE THERE. A WE LEARNED A
LOT OF INFORMATION AT THOSE
WITH WITH WHAT OUR CUSTOMERS
NEED IN AND WHAT THEY EXPECT-
AND THEN WE DO AFTER ACTION
REVIEWS AFTER EVERY BAND SO
AFTER OUR OCTOBER. AND NOVEMBER
ADVANCE WE- HELD TEN DIFFERENT
SESSIONS WITH INTERNAL AND
EXTERNAL STAKEHOLDERS- CALLOW
YES- UP FIRST RESPONDERS LOCAL
FIRE AGENCIES WALLS- HOST OF
PEOPLE FROM INSIDE AS TEACHING
NEED TO. IDENTIFY WAYS THAT WE
CAN GET BETTER AT THIS- AND SO
HERE'S JUST SOME OF SOME OF THE
LESSONS LEARNED BUT- OBVIOUSLY
GOING INTO THE EVENT WE SAW
WHAT WAS HAPPENING AND SOME
OTHER PLACES WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT. OUR WEBSITE WAS ABLE
TO HANDLE ANY POSSIBLE TRAFFIC
WE CAN ANTICIPATE- GOING
THROUGH THE FIRE WEATHER EVENT-
OF. THE NEXT FOR BOTH ARE I
CAN'T OVER EMPHASIZE ENOUGH-
IT'S REALLY ALL THE WORK THAT
YOU DO WITH ALL THESE
ORGANIZATIONS AND AGENCIES. AND
IN COURT IN COURT OFFSEASON.
THAT HELPS YOU PERFORM BETTER
DURING THE- AND SO WE MEET WITH.
NINETY SOMETHING NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS OVER TO. AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
WE NEED ALL OUR FIRE AGENCIES
ON A REGULAR BASIS. OF ME WITH
OFFER FOR SPONSORS LEAST EIGHT.
A AND THIS. US ALL NEVER THIS
AND THE SAY. BET WITH POSSIBLE
FOR THE COMMUNITIES WE SERVE
AND IN SOME. THESE LEARNED
OFFICE FED INTO THE FOR
ADDITIONAL WHETHER STATE AND
THIRTY SECTIONAL I DEVICE THAT
I DESCRIBED THOSE WERE LESSONS
LEARNED ON MORE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE SIDE OF THINGS-
AND THESE ALL HELP. WITH THIS
DISEASE GOAL OF OBVIOUSLY
REDUCING THE RISK OF WILDFIRE
BECAUSE OUR INFRASTRUCTURE BUT
ALSO MITIGATING THE EFFECTS OF.
THE S. P. S. IMPACTS AND THEN
JUST TO BE A LITTLE BIT MORE
SPECIFIC ABOUT THE SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT THAT WERE DOING HIS
IMPROVEMENTS FOR TWENTY TWENTY
ON THE- ON THE LAST SLIDE- I'VE
ALREADY TALKED ABOUT THE
SECTIONALISM DEVICES IN AND
WEATHER STATIONS- I ALSO TALKED
ABOUT. THE UNDERGROUND INTO THE
COMMUNITY CENTER SO THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE DOING AND THE MICRO
GRIDS THAT WILL FEED THE
COMMUNITY CENTERS THAT WERE NOT
UNDERGROUND UNTIL. AND SO FOR
THOSE TWO PARTICULAR ITEMS IT'S
NOT ABOUT THE SEVEN HUNDRED
SEVENTY FOUR AND TWO AND FORTY
CUSTOMERS ABOUT WHAT TYPE OF
CUSTOMERS THAT THEY ARE. AND SO
THOSE ARE LISTED DOWN HERE
BELOW WITH THE TWENTY NINE
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES- WE DE
ENERGIZED TWENTY THREE SCHOOLS
LAST ALL- TEN OF THOSE SCHOOLS
WILL REMAIN ON THIS FALL. WE
HAVE THE SAME EXACT CONDITIONS
THIS YEAR- AS WELL AS EIGHT
FIRE STATIONS ONE POLICE
STATION AN URGENT CARE FACILITY
SIXTY TWO COMMUNICATION SITES
IN THE WATER FACILITIES- AND SO
THIS THIS PIE CHART IS
OBVIOUSLY A MAKING THE
ASSUMPTION THAT WE HAVE THE
EXACT SAME WEATHER CONDITIONS
IN THE EXACT AREAS BUT- OF THE
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED CUSTOMERS THAT WE DE
ENERGIZED LAST YEAR. WITH THESE
IMPROVEMENTS WE WOULD OF- SAVE
31% OF THOSE. THIS FALL. AND
THE- OUTLOOK FOR TO THAT THE
QUESTIONS IN THE QUESTION
ANSWER SESSION. BOB OKAY- I
WILL- PROBABLY BE IN AND OUT OF
SOME PREPARED REMARKS AS WELL
AS- REFERENCING THE- SLIDE TO
CAROL TRY TO GET TO THIS VERY
QUICKLY BECAUSE I KNOW THERE'S
A MANY QUESTIONS THAT- WE NEED
TO ANSWER TODAY- WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE SAME EVENT
ESSENTIALLY OCTOBER ANOTHER WAS
A DIRECTIVE HERE BUT- I SHOULD
POINT OUT THAT WE ALSO BEGIN
STANDING UP OUR PS PS EFFORTS-
IT AROUND MID SUMMER I THINK
JUNE LIKE JUNE WAS THE FIRST
TIME WE STOOD UP- WE HAVE A
VERY SIMILAR PHILOSOPHY- AS- AS
FAR AS- THE ENERGIES ATION-
TYPICALLY AS I LOOK OVER THE
ENTIRE. SPAN OF- PS PS EVENTS
OVER THE YEAR- WE ROUGHLY DE
ENERGIZED AROUND 10% OF THE
TIME WE NOTIFY SO WE HAVE A AND
WE LEAN IN THE NOTIFICATIONS WE
THINK EARLY WARNING PREPARATION
IS A IS IMPORTANT. THE
CONSEQUENCE OF THAT CAN BE
NOTIFICATION FATIGUE SO WE'RE
WELL AWARE OF THAT BUT WE THINK
OF LETTING PEOPLE KNOW IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL- SO THE
AND- WITH A WERE PRETTY GOOD AT
THIS- MY SAID TEN PERCENT- IS
PROBABLY ABOUT WHERE WE FEEL WE
SHOULD BE RIGHT NOW- AGAIN I
MENTION THE FIVE MILLION
CUSTOMERS- METERED ACCOUNTS-
RELATIVE TO THE WORST- WORST
EVENT WE HAD WITH A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DE ENERGIZED. IT'S
ABOUT 2% OF OUR CUSTOMERS- BUT
THAT DOESN'T MEAN A LOT TO YOU
KNOW THAT ARE OUR SECTIONAL
RISING ABILITY IS GREAT WHEN WE
ARE. REMAIN ENERGIZED BUT IF
YOU'RE NOT- NOT SO GREAT SO
THAT'S THE AREA WE'RE SPENDING
A LOT OF TIME. OF FOCUSING. I
HAVE TO SAY IN AND ONE IN FOR
SO. THIS I IN OUR POST. AND WE
ALSO WILL NOT RE ENERGIZE UNTIL
WE- DO A PATROL OF OUR LINES.
WHERE ARE- CRUZ FEEL CREWS HAVE
EYES ON THE EQUIPMENT. IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT WE CAN'T DO THIS
REMOTELY. WE HAVE TO BE THERE
TO SEE WHAT'S OUT THERE. AND
WHEN WE DID THIS WE FOUND FORTY
INSTANCES. OF DAMAGE TO OUR
LINES OR VEGETATION ON THOSE
LINES THAT WE FEEL COULD HAVE
CAUSED. A CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES. IN IT DID NOT. DID
NOT BECAUSE WE DE ENERGIZED AND
THAT'S WHY THIS NEEDS TO.
REMAIN A KEY PART OF OUR OUR
ARSENAL HERE. NOW AGAIN THIS IS
IMPORTANT IT'S IMPORTANT PART
OF OUR- ARE- MITIGATION
EFFORTS- BUT THE MORE OF OUR
MITIGATION EFFORTS WE JUST
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER COVER
CONDUCTOR- THE MORE SECTIONAL
RISING THE ADVANCE WEATHER
STATIONS- THE LESS. IMPORTANT
THAT THIS PARTICULAR TOOL HAS-
IN IN THE WAY WE MITIGATE
WILDFIRE RISK. WE ALSO HAVE
PARTNERED WITH OUR COMMUNITIES
OUR FIRST RESPONDERS. NOW WE
HAVE TO DEAL WITH FIFTEEN
COUNTIES AND SO EACH ONE OF
THOSE HAS- THEIR OWN FIRST
RESPONDER TEAMS. AS WELL AS CAL
FIRE SO IT'S A PRETTY BIG FOOT
PRINT. OF FIRST RESPONDERS IN
COMMUNITIES WE DEAL WITH BUT WE
DO WE ENGAGE WITH THEM VERY
ACTIVELY- WERE OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY BEFORE EVENTS AND
AFTER EVENTS. AND I DO HAVE
BEEN- IN- IN THOSE AREAS AFTER
A LEADING UP TO EVENTS SO I
UNDERSTAND SOME OF THE
CONCERNS. OF MANY OF THE
CONCERNS AND WE'RE GOING TO
ADDRESS THOSE. NOW WE HAVE A
SIMILAR- KIND OF RUN UP- BASED
ON WHETHER- IT'S- ROUGHLY THREE
DAYS BEFORE AN EVENT. HOW WE
SEE IT COMING THAT'S WILL
NOTIFY- OR FIRST RESPONDER
PARTNERS AND- GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES. OTHER CRITICAL-
INFRASTRUCTURE PROVIDERS-
AROUND FORTY EIGHT HOURS IN
ADVANCE OF THE VENT IF WE HAVE
THE WEATHER FORECASTS TO
DEMONSTRATE IT WILL ALSO NOTIFY
CUSTOMERS- AGAIN THIS IS THIS
IS THE WEATHER- OUR TOOLS ARE
ARE VERY GOOD. WE BELIEVE UP
BUT IT'S THE WEATHER AND SO
THERE ARE TIMES WHEN YOU DON'T
HAVE A FORTY EIGHT HOUR
NOTIFICATION. AND WE UNDERSTAND
THEY CAN BE VERY CHALLENGING TO
OUR OUR CUSTOMERS- BUT ALL THIS
INFORMATION HELPS US TO MAKE
THE KIND OF DECISIONS WE THINK
WE NEED TO MAKE IN THE INTEREST
OF PUBLIC SAFETY. NOW WE DID
LOOK AT LESSONS OR AND I SHOULD
SAY WE LOOK AT OCTOBER BUT THE
REAL TRUTH OF THIS IS. EVERY
SINGLE EVENT THAT WE GO THROUGH
IS A LESSONS LEARNED
OPPORTUNITY. AND EACH EVENT
WHETHER IT'S A SMALL THEN
WITHOUT ANYBODY DE ENERGIZED.
OR A BIG EVENT- WE LEARN. AND
SOME OTHER THINGS THAT WERE
BRING TO FOR- WE KNOW THAT
DURING THESE EVENTS ARE WEBSITE
COULD NOT HANDLE THE TRAFFIC WE
FIX THAT. WE'VE UPGRADED OUR
SERVERS AND WE CAN HANDLE THE
TRAFFIC. AND WE'VE TESTED UNDER
THE MOST EXTREME MODELED
CIRCUMSTANCE SO WE FIX THAT.
ANOTHER BIG AREA WAS OUR
CIRCUIT MAPS SO- WE PUT CIRCUIT
MAPS UP AND- WE FOUND THAT MOST
CUSTOMERS DID NOT SEE A LOT OF
MEANINGFUL INFORMATION THERE.
SO WE HAVE NOW IS MORE
INTERACTIVE SYSTEM YOU CAN PLUG
IN YOUR ADDRESS. AND WE'LL TELL
YOU WHAT TO EXPECT IF YOU'RE ON
THE LIST FOR PSP S. OR IF YOU
ARE IN FACT- DE ENERGIZED IF
YOU'RE SOMEWHERE ELSE TYPING
YOUR ADDRESS IN- ANOTHER KEY
AREA. NON SEC CUSTOMERS SO
GROUPS SUCH AS RENTERS TENANTS-
YOU HAVE A FAMILY MEMBER IN A
CERTAIN AREA. WE CAN TYPE IN
THE ZIP CODE AND GET AUTOMATIC
PS PS NOTIFICATIONS AS WELL SO
IT'S PRETTY IMPORTANT PIECE OF
INFORMATION. BACK GENERATION SO
WE TALKED A BIT ABOUT BACKUP
GENERATION WAS FOR A MINUTE
MORE THIS. OUR MOST VULNERABLE
CUSTOMERS ARE THE ONES THAT WE
CALL CRITICAL CARE THEY HAVE
MEDICAL DEVICE NEEDS- SO WE
ARE- ARE ABOUT. BEGINNING A
PROGRAM WHAT WE WILL REIMBURSE
CERTAIN INCOME QUALIFIED
CRITICAL CARE CUSTOMERS. FOR
THE COST OF THE BACKUP BATTERY
SO WILL HAVE. TWENTY FOUR HOURS
OF CAPABILITY- AND THIS WILL BE
PROVIDED AT NO COST TO OUR
CUSTOMERS. SO OUR MEN COME
QUALIFIED CUSTOMERS THAT FALL
IN THE CRITICAL CARE.
CATEGORIES SO IT'S A IT'S A BIG
AREA OF CONCERN. NOW WE TAKE
SPECIAL STEPS WITH THOSE
CUSTOMERS. IN THE NOTIFICATION
PROCESS IS WE ACTUALLY IF WE
DON'T REACH THEM VIA TELEPHONE
DURING PSP US. WE WILL SEND ONE
OF OUR CREW TO THEIR DOOR. TO
KNOCK OUT TO MAKE SURE THEY'VE
GOT THE WORD SO WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF- WAYS WERE TRYING TO
PROTECT- THAT CUSTOMER CLASS.
BUT BUT THAT'S IMPORTANT IN
BACK OF GENERATION IS ONE OF
THEM. THAT WE SHOULD WE MENTION
SCHOOLS- OUR TALLY WAS FIFTY
FIVE SCHOOLS- THAT WERE DE
ENERGIZED- WE KNOW THAT'S FIFTY
FIVE SCHOOLS TOO MANY- WE ARE
ABOUT TO- OF WE BROKEN GROUND
WITH US AND YOU SEE TO HIGH
SCHOOL- IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY
WITH A- MICROGROOVE PROJECT
THERE. IT'S A SOLAR BATTERY
UNIT- SO WE WILL ACTUALLY HAVE
AN AUTOMATIC BUS TRANSFER THAT
WHEN THE GREAT GOES DOWN. IT
WILL GO UP SO WE'RE ACTUALLY
WORKING. THIS WATER SEWER
MOVING FORWARD IN MANY AREAS.
NOW THE OTHER PIECE- I'M ABOUT
TO CLOSE HERE BUT I DO THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT WE MENTION
CUSTOMER CARE THAT THE NORMALLY
CRITICAL FORCE- BUT THERE'S THE
OPERATIONAL PRUDENT AS WELL- I
I'D LIKE TO JUST POINT OUT
SLIDE TWELVE- WE COVER SOME OF
THE AREAS. OF THE KEY KEY
BUCKETS OF AREAS. ALLOW FOR
MITIGATION- AND THE OPERATIONAL
SPACE- AS WELL AS CUSTOMER CARE
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT. I
MENTIONED SWITCHING PLAYBOOK SO
I WILL COVER THAT ANYMORE HERE-
TARGET A GREAT HARDENING. OUR
PS PS EXPERIENCE AND EVENTS
THAT WE SAW. LAST YEAR. AND NOT
JUST IN OCTOBER- AND LET US TO
IDENTIFY CIRCUITS THAT ARE
FREQUENTLY MORE OFTEN THAN
OTHERS DE ENERGIZED. SO WE'RE
TARGETING THOSE FOR EXPEDITED.
COVERING OF THE CONDUCTOR OR
OTHER ENGINEERING FIXES IT
COULD BE A SWITCH- IT COULD BE
A PEACE UNDERGROUND AND-
THERE'S OTHER THINGS WE CAN DO
OUTSIDE OF COVERING AND WE'RE
LOOKING TO DO THOSE. TO REDUCE
THE IMPACT OF THE SPS- DETAILED
ENGINEERING SYSTEM OF
VALUATIONS WHAT WE CAN EVEN
CONFIGURE CIRCUITS IN ADVANCE
OF THE HIGH FIRE. RISK
SOMETIMES CIRCUITS ARE SUPPLIED
FOR RELIABILITY FROM ANOTHER
SUBSTATION- BUT SOMETIMES WILL
TAKE A RELIABILITY. IN GENERAL
TO. PUT THEM THE CIRCUIT THAT
BE BE MORE RESILIENT IN A WHILE
FAR TO TUITION SO THESE ARE
THINGS THAT HAVEN'T.
HISTORICALLY DONE WILL DO THAT
NOW. OUT MY GRADES PENSION.
EARLIER THE- OTHER KEY. THIS IS
MY TO ALL THING. BUT WE LOOK
JUST AT HE- SWITCHING PLAYBOOKS.
AND WE DID A Mà. RELIES ON
SAME FOR HAPPENED. YEAR THAT
WOULD HAPPEN THIS YEAR SOME
KIND OF A ALL THINGS BEING
EQUAL- W FOUND THE JUSTICE
SWITCHING PLAYBOOKS. COULD TO
REDUCE THE IMPACT BY AT LEAST
30% SO IT'S WE THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF THE AREA FOR
IMPROVEMENT. THERE ARE MOVING
AGGRESSIVELY TO ACCOMPLISH. SO
THAT THAT'S REALLY THE PREPARED
STATEMENT OF WHAT HAVE WE TAKE
THIS REALLY SERIOUSLY. AS A-
ENERGY PROFESSIONAL FOR MOST OF
MY CAREER- INCLUDING MY-
MILITARY EXPERIENCE IS PROBABLY
AROUND THIRTY FIVE YEARS- WE
MEASURE OURSELVES HAVE
HISTORICALLY MEASURE OURSELVES
BY RELIABILITY METRICS RIGHT.
SOMETHING CALLED SADIE SYSTEM
AVERAGE- INSTANT DURATION INDEX
HOW OFTEN YOU ARE ONLINE HOW
LITTLE TIME YOU SPEND. DE
ENERGIZING CUSTOMER SO MAKING A
DECISION TO DE ENERGIZE A
CUSTOMER IT'S NOT HARD NOT
HISTORICALLY IN OUR DNA. BUT
PUBLIC SAFETY IS OUR NUMBER ONE
OBJECTIVE AND THAT TRUMPS
EVERYTHING. AND THAT'S WHY WE
HAVE THIS IS A KEY PART OF OUR
MITIGATION SUITE. WE UNDERSTAND
THIS IS VERY HARD FOR CUSTOMERS
AND IT'S HARD FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES AND THE AND YOUR
OUR FAMILY. WHO HAVE SUBJECT TO
A PS PS BUT BUT WE TAKE IT.
WE'RE GOING TO GET BETTER-
WE'RE COMMITTED TO THAT BUT
POINT PART OF THE PROGRAM. THIS
IS HOW. MANY SO THIS WE ARE IN.
OUR PS PRO. IN A- AND IN AN
EFFORT TO MAKE THE- SMALLER
SURE. AND SMARTER. WHILE
WORKING TO KEEP OUR CUSTOMERS
AND COMMUNITY SAFE DURING TIMES
OF SEVERE WEATHER AND HEIGHT
WILD FIRE RISK. THE SOLE
PURPOSE OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
SHUT UP. AS MAKE YOUR UTILITIES
OF SAID IS TO REDUCE THE RISK
OF CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES
DURING SEVERE WEATHER. OUR GOAL
IS TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
CUSTOMERS THAT ARE IMPACTED AND
THE LENGTH OF TIME THAT
CUSTOMERS ARE IMPACTED EVERY
YEAR. WE WILL REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF CUSTOMER IMPACTS THROUGH
IMPROVED METEOROLOGICAL DATA
AND FORECASTING- SAFELY.
MINIMIZING TRANSMISSION IMPACTS
AND DEPLOYING CUSTOMER CENTRIC
SOLUTIONS INCLUDING TEMPORARY
AND PERMANENT GENERATION AT
SUBSTATIONS MID FEEDER
MICROGRAPHS AND SUPPORTING
COMMUNITY ENABLED MICRO GRIDS.
BUT WE ARE ALSO SEEKING THE CUT
THE RESTORATION TIMES IN HALF
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER WITH
ADDITIONAL AIR RESOURCES TO AID
WITH PATROLLING OF THE LINES
AS- ALL OF THE UTILITIES HAVE
FOUND EVEN IN THE MOST SEVERE
ADVANCE. THERE ARE VEGETATION
IMPACTS ON OUR FACILITIES THAT
HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO HAVE COST
A WILDFIRE. FROM. A CUSTOMER
AND COMMUNITY PERSPECTIVE WE
ARE LISTENING TO OUR CUSTOMERS
ABOUT HOW WE CAN DO BETTER FOR
FUTURE EVENTS BY TAKING
FEEDBACK AND ACTING ON WHAT WE
HEAR. MUCH LIKE OUR MEMBER
UTILITIES. FOLLOWING THE
OUTAGES IN TWENTY NINETEEN- WE
IMMEDIATELY BOLSTERED OUR
WEBSITE AND OUR CALL CENTER
RESOURCES TO WITHSTAND THE
HIGHER LEVEL OF TRAFFIC DURING
A P. S. P. S. EVENT AND WILL
CONTINUE TO MAKE IMPROVEMENTS-
TO THE INFORMATION OF RESOURCES
AVAILABLE. WE ARE UPDATING HOW
WE ALERT OUR MEMBERS ABOUT PS
PSE EVENTS BY SENDING OUT
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ABOUT
WHEN POWER WILL BE SHUT OFF FOR
SAFETY. AND WHEN IT WILL BE
RESTORED. WE'RE WORKING WITH
THE LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO
IMPROVE THE LOCATIONS THE
AVAILABILITY AND RESOURCES
PROVIDED AT OUR COMMUNITY
RESOURCES. COMMUNITY RESOURCE
CENTERS I'VE BEEN ACTUALLY
DEPLOYED IN THE MIDDLE OF
EVENTS. AND HER DAD DIRECTLY
FROM CUSTOMERS WHO WERE HIGHLY
FRUSTRATED AT BEING OUT OF
POWER- SO VERY FAMILIAR WITH
THOSE. CONCERNS UP WE X.
ESTABLISHED AN ACCESS AND
FUNCTIONAL NEEDS ADVISORY
COUNCIL. TO INFORM OUR
OUTREACH. PROGRAMS OF RESOURCES
FOR THE A. F. AND COMMUNITY AND
MEDICALLY SENSITIVE POPULATIONS.
WE ARE PARTNERING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LEARNINGS AT LIVING
CENTERS TO HELP SERVE THE F.
AND COMMUNITY BEFORE DURING AND
AFTER A P. S. P. S. EVENT OR
OTHER SYSTEM EMERGENCY IN
ADDITION TO THE FORMING
COLLABORATIONS WITH CAN MEET HE
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS WERE
TAKING. OUR ALERTS A STEP
FURTHER FOR THE MEDICAL
BASELINE CUSTOMERS AS I BE
BELIEVE THAT SEAT DOES IF WE
DON'T REACH THE CUSTOMER
DIRECTLY WE SEND AN EMPLOYEE TO
KNOCK ON THEIR DOOR TO MAKE
SURE THEY ARE AWARE OF THE
COMING PS PS EVENT. BY THE
NUMBERS AND TWENTY TWENTY.
WE'RE HOSTING A SERIES OF OPEN
HOUSES AND WEBINARS TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION TO OUR CUSTOMERS
AND COMMUNITIES ABOUT OUR
TREATMENTS AND PS PS
PREPAREDNESS. WE'RE ALREADY
WORKING CLOSELY WITH LOCAL
STATE AND TRIBAL OFFICIALS TO
BE BETTER COORDINATED WITH THE
PS PS EVENTS. WERE UTILIZING
LISTENING SESSIONS WHICH WE
JUST CONCLUDED IN FEBRUARY- WE
WILL BE IMPLEMENTING EXERCISES
AND PLANNING MEETINGS TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND AND ADDRESS CONCERNS
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. READY FOR-
THAT'S THE CONCLUSION OF MY
PREPARED REMARKS. THANK YOU THE
STRESS. I WANT TO ADDRESS MY
QUESTION STATUS AND THAT'S MY
SERVICE AREA. FIRST AYE AYE I
DO WANT TO. THANK EDISON FOR
RESPONDING WE HAD LOTS OF PHONE
CALLS FROM OUR COMMUNITY DURING
THOSE SHUT OFFS- GREAT CONCERN
THERE HAD BEEN A COMMUNITY
MEETING- IN ONE AREA THAT GOT A
LITTLE BIT OUT OF HAND I
UNDERSTAND- BUT I APPRECIATED
THAT THE SECOND MEETING WITH
WITH MY OFFICE. WHO IT WAS IT
WAS VERY IMPORTANT FOR THE
CUSTOMERS TO HEAR FROM EDISON
ABOUT WHAT WAS HAPPENING THE
END RESULT MAY NOT HAVE BEEN
WHAT THEY WANTED TO HEAR BUT-
THE- ONE THING THAT I DO WANT
TO KNOW IS. YOUR COMMUNICATION
WITH THE MEMBERS OUR OFFICES-
THAT ARE IN YOUR SERVICER THIS
WOULD GO TO ALL OF YOU TO REACH
OUT TO US BECAUSE YOU CAN REST
ASSURED THAT WE'RE GETTING THE
PHONE CALLS. AND WE WHEN WE ARE
TOLD WILL HAVE THEM GO TO THE
WEBSITE. YEAH I APPRECIATE THAT
YOU ACKNOWLEDGE THAT YOUR
WEBSITE. DID NOT TAKE CARE OF
YOUR CUSTOMERS YOU WEREN'T SET
UP FOR THAT TIME AND I'M GLAD
THAT THAT HAS CHANGED. AT I
THINK THAT WE'RE GOING THROUGH
SOMETHING THAT'S NEW- BUT KNOW
THAT YOU CAN COUNT ON USWE'RE
VERY CONCERNED FOR YOUR
CUSTOMERS OUR CONSTITUENTS-
THEY THEY REACH OUT TO YOU BUT
WHEN THEY DON'T REACH YOU THEY
DO REACH OUT TO US. SO I WAS
INTERESTED IN KNOWING A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT. YOUR YOUR YOUR
PLAN TO. THEY THEY SAY THAT
IT'S LIKE A SURGEON'S KNIFE
THAT TO YOU YOU WANT TO BE VERY
SPECIFIC ABOUT WHERE THE SHUT
OFF IS BUT THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN
LAST TIME WHAT IS BEING DONE
SPECIFICALLY SO THAT IT IS MORE
OF A SURGICAL SHUT OFF AS
OPPOSED TO JUST SHUTTING OFF
THE GRID. IN SOME OF MY CITIES
IT WENT FROM HIGH RISK ALL THE
WAY DOWN TO DOWNTOWN WHERE. THE
CABLES WERE UNDERGROUND SO
THERE WASN'T ZERO RISK. WHAT
ARE WE DOING WHAT WHAT ARE WHAT
IS THAT ISN'T DOING
SPECIFICALLY SURE THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
FEEDBACK TO I THINK WE ARE
LEARNING- ABOUT ALL OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS- AND WHERE. WE
NEED TO BE REACHING OUT MORE
PROACTIVELY SO I THINK THAT'S
PART OF THE BIG LESSONS LEARNED
THAT WE'VE CONTINUED TO BUILD
INTO OUR PROGRAM SO THAT REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT FEEDBACK- INTO
IT IT VERY MUCH ALONG THE LINES
OF WHAT I. TALKED ABOUT EARLIER
ONE AGAIN IT'S- THE TO DO THIS
AND SOMETIMES WE USE THE WORD-
PRECISE OR GROUP MUELLER OR
SURGICAL- BUT THIS THEME IS THE
SAME WHICH IS- THESE CONDITIONS
ARE OFTEN VERY DIFFERENT SOME
OF OUR CIRCUITS ARE TENS OF
MILES LONG- SO AS YOU CAN AND-
BEEN A HIGH WINDS THAT. AT ONE
SPOT THIS. THE OTHER. AND THE-
USER. TO SECTOR. SOMEONE THE
TALK ABOUT IS CRITICAL SO THE
DEVICE TO BE THE- AND WE'RE
PUTTING EVEN MORE THOSE OUT BUT
WE ARE. WE THINK WE'RE IN
PRETTY GOOD SHAPE THERE WITH AS
A SAID AROUND FOUR PER CIRCUIT-
BUT THEN MAKING DECISIONS
AROUND THAT AND THAT'S WHERE I
TALKED ABOUT THE PLAY BOOK SO-
FOR EACH OF OUR CIRCUITS IN
HIGH FIRE RISK AREAS IN THERE'S
OVER A THOUSAND OF THOSE- WE
STARTED THIS YEAR. WITH THE
ONES THAT WERE- HEAVILY
IMPACTED BY PSP US AND WE LOOK
AT THOSE FIRST DEVELOP THE
PLAYBOOKS THOSE EXIST NOW. AND
WE'VE WE'VE DONE THAT FOR THE
REST OF THE CIRCUITS AS WELL.
SO WE HAVE WHEN WE'RE THE
SITUATION BUT WE'RE GOING TO
DO- WE ALSO BY THE WAY NOW HAVE
A PERMANENT FEATURE OF OUR TEAM
DURING SB. SO OUR TYPICAL
CRACKED AND WE HAVE BEEN ON THE
FEMA MODEL FOR MANY MANY YEARS
NOW TERMS OF THE INCIDENT
MANAGEMENT TEAM AN INCIDENT
COMMAND STRUCTURE- BUT WE HAD A
OPERATING SYSTEM THAT WOULD
MOBILIZE EVERYBODY NEEDED FOR
PS PS- WHEN THOSE EVENTS OCCUR
WE NOW HAVE A PERMANENT STAFF
THAT IS CONSTANTLY LOOKING AT
ALL OF THE CIRCUITS AND HOW TO
MANAGE THEM IN PS BECAUSE
EVENTS SO THAT'S THAT'S A NEW
THING T STARTED LAST PSP A
SEASON THEY GOT NEW TOOLS NOW-
THEN OF COURSE THE MICRO GRIDS
WE TALKED ABOUT HELPING OUR
CUSTOMERS WHEN THINGS HAPPEN
BECAUSE E SAID SOMETIMES. THE
RIGHT DECISION IS DE ENERGIZING
THAT CIRCUIT SO YOU GET IT AS
SMALL AS YOU CAN AND THEN WHEN
YOU HAVE TO BE ENERGIZED
SOMEBODY WE HAVE TO TAKE CARE
OF OUR CUSTOMERS SO WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF CUSTOMER CARE
INITIATIVES IN SOME CASES
PROVIDING POTABLE WATER IS IN
THE ARSENAL IN SOME CASES- IT
MAY BE HELPING OUT WITH
GENERATORS SO WE'VE GOT A
DIFFERENT SUITE OF THINGS THAT
WE ARE LOOKING AT DOING IN
HELPING OUR CUSTOMERS THROUGH
THESE TOUGH SITUATIONS SO. IT
HAPPENS ON INFRASTRUCTURE IT
HAPPENS WITH CUSTOMER CARE THAT
HAPPENS WITH WHETHER THE ONE
OTHER THING WE THE DANCE- OUR
WEATHER PREDICTION CAPABILITY
SIGNIFICANTLY WE- NOW HAVE TO
SUPERCOMPUTERS- BOB WE'VE HIRED-FIRE SCIENTISTS THAT WAS ABOUT
A YEAR AGO- WHICH WAS KIND OF
MARKS WHERE WE ARE AS AN
INDUSTRY HAVE BEEN HIRED YOUR
OWN FIRE SCIENTISTS KIND OF
TOLD YOU WHERE WHERE WE ARE
RIGHT NOW- BUT HAVING THAT
PREDICTIVE CAPABILITY WITH THE
WEATHER STATIONS WILL NEW
WEATHER MODELING- PUTS US IN A
PLACE THAT WE CAN PRODUCE THESE
EVENTS EVEN SOONER. THAN CREWS
TO INSPECT MIND AHEAD OF TIME
WHICH WE ALWAYS DO MAKE REPAIRS
IF WE CAN UP INTO THE EVENT AND
THEN MINIMIZING NOT A
DISRUPTION THAT DOES HAPPEN
WHEN WE DO THE PS BECAUSE
ACTIONS. TO OTHER QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE STRUCTURE OF THE
SECTIONAL ISING THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT ARE THERE ANY
PARTICULAR COMMUTE TO USE THE
TERM LOOKING OUT THAT WE CAN
SHARE WITH OUR COMMUNITIES YET
WE WILL- I DON'T HAVE THE LIST
IN FRONT OF ME BUT ARE ARE.
TEAMS ARE REACHING TO CAN. AND
WHEN WE GO OUT OF THE COMMUNITY
WE WILL BE SHARING WITH THEM-
SOME SPECIFICS ON WHAT WE'VE
DONE. WHAT CIRCUIT WHAT LINES
HAVE BEEN COVERED THAT WILL BE
AND WHAT WILL SHARE ALL THAT
INFORMATION. AND HOW WE'RE
THINKING ABOUT THE CHANGES THE
P. S. P. S. DOT WHERE WE CAN
SUBMIT THEM WE WILL CERTAINLY
COMMUNICATE. AGAIN WE WE'RE
WE'RE LEVERAGING THE SEGMENT.
CAPE ACTUALIZING A TO A GREATER
DEGREE THAN WE HAVE IN STORE
MANY OF THE DEVICES ALREADY
EXIST WHAT IT. WILL USE A MORE-
AND WE'LL TALK ABOUT WHERE
WE'RE PUTTING THOSE AND
SOMETIMES IT TAKES. A COUPLE OF
YEARS AND- SOME AREAS WILL.
MOVE TO THE FRONT OF THE QUEUE.
UP TO GET THAT DONE SOONER BUT-
WE CAN GET THAT INFORMATION TO
THE COMMUNITIES AND ARE DOING
THAT WE HAVE. SCHEDULED EVENTS
IN NUMBER THE COMMUNITIES
ALREADY FOR MARCH AND APRIL
PARTICULAR THE ONES THAT ARE.
EXPERIENCE A LOT OF PAIN FROM
THE AT THE SPS OFFENSE SO. ONE
MAKE SURE WE HAD THIRDS. OF
THOSE FOLKS FIRST. IN MY LAST
QUESTION IF I MAY. THE
GENERATORS I KNOW DURING THE
LAST PS PS- A NUMBER OF US WERE
PART OF A. CONVERSATION WERE
MANY OF YOU OR MANY OF YOUR
REPRESENTATIVES WERE WORLD
CALLS THERE WAS DISCUSSION
ABOUT GENERATORS BEING OFFERED
BUT NOT ALL THE ARE YOU USE
HAVE THESE AVAILABLE. ARE YOU
ALL GOING TO HAVE THOSE IN
EDISON SPECIFICALLY- WILL YOU
NOW MAKE THOSE AVAILABLE TO-
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY THAT
ARE ASKING FOR THE GENERATORS.
WE ARE MAKING AVAILABLE I WILL
SAY THIS IS A GENERALLY CASE BY
CASE BASIS IN MANY CASES THESE
ARE IN THE INCIDENT- WE DID
MAKE- ONE AVAILABLE TO CAL WAS
ON ELEMENTARY FOR EXAMPLE TO
KEEP THEM OPEN- IT'LL MANY
TIMES HIS CONVERSATIONS WITH-
WITH OUR COMMUNITY- WE
GENERALLY DON'T PROVIDE AN
INDIVIDUAL CUSTOMER AT A
HOUSEHOLD WITH THE GENERATOR
LIKE TO SOME EXTREME NEED
AGAIN. THERE CAN BE CASE BY
CASE EVENTS- WE DO WANT TO
ENCOURAGE OUR CUSTOMER BASE TO
DEVELOP. SOME LEVEL OF
RESILIENCY AS WELL RECOGNIZING
THE FACT THAT PS PS IS ONE OF A
NUMBER OF CONDITIONS THAT CAN
CAUSE. YOU TO LOSE POWER A
LARGE EARTHQUAKE FOR VAN
EXAMPLE IS LOOK BECAUSE
PROLONGED. THE AND THAT HAVE
VERY LITTLE WARNING SO SOME OF
RESUME TO BE DOING ENCOURAGE
AND WE'VE GOT PRO. BY THE WAY
WERE PILOTING A REBATE PROGRAM
FOR INDIVIDUAL CUSTOMERS- WHERE
THEY CAN- HAVE A REBATE IF THEY
PROCURE A GENERATOR- BUT FOR
LARGER CUSTOMERS ESSENTIAL USE
CUSTOMERS- THERE'S A
CONVERSATIONS WILL HAVE IN THE
EVENT. AND WE ARE LINING UP
GENERATORS IN ADVANCE OF THE
EVENTS- AS YOU CAN IMAGINE THAT
SUPPLY CHAIN IS AN ISSUE. AND
WHAT WE DID SEE IS LAST YEAR-
THE EVENTS AT NORTH FIRST- SO
THE- GENERATOR POOL WAS- WAS
PULLED THERE AND THERE WAS
LIMITED AVAILABILITYDOWN SOUTH
FOR GENERATORS- DURING SOME OF
OUR EVENTS SO. THESE ARE THINGS
ARE WORKING THROUGH ONE OF THE
LESSONS LEARNED WE BUILT INTO
OUR OUR PLANS FOR THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU PICTURE. SO I'M BILL
QUIRK THE CHAIR HAS TO GO
PRESENTED ANOTHER. SO HE
COULDN'T STAY AND HE HAS PUT ME
TEMPORARILY IN CHARGE. OF
MISSED DOCTOR WOULD WOULD WOULD
LIKE TO ASK A QUESTION NEXT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR YOU'RE DOING A FINE JOB
BY THE WAY. OF MY QUESTION IS
GONNA BE AROUND- MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES SPECIFICALLY NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA POWER AGENCY- I HAVE
TO MUNICIPAL UTILITIES IN MY
DISTRICT. AND ONE OF THE-
FRUSTRATIONS WE'VE HAD. IS HAS
BEEN COORDINATION AND
COMMUNICATION- AS A AS A MEMBER
OF THE LEGISLATURE I DON'T LIKE
GETTING CALLS FROM MY UTILITY
DIRECTOR ST I CAN'T TALK TO
ANYBODY A P. JEANNIE. THE
PERSON I'M TALKING TO IS A
PUBLIC A- OF PUBLIC RELATIONS
PERSON. NOT A SYSTEMS PERSON.
AND SO AS YOU'RE LOOKING AT
CITIES- THAT- HAVE THEIR OWN
UTILITY THEY HAVE THEIR OWN
LINE CREWS THEY'VE THEY'VE
INSPECTED THEIR LINES. IN YET
THEY'RE WAITING. A LONG TIME.
TO GET RE ENERGIZE WHEN THEY'RE
READY TO GO AND SO I WOULD ASK
THAT YOU HAVE SOME SORT OF
LIAISON SOME SORT OF DIRECT
LINK TO GIVE THESE CITIES THERE
SIXTEEN. UTILITIES THAT
REPRESENT SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA- AND I HEARD FROM
TWO OF THEM THE ONLY TWO OF MY
DISTRICT THAT THEY COULDN'T
TALK TO ANYBODY TO GET
INFORMATION. SO WHAT ARE YOU
DOING TO HELP IN THAT REGARD.
SO WITH AND PARTNERING WITH-
STATE AND COUNTY ORGANIZATIONS.
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY FIRE
SEASON WE WILL HAVE P. JEANNIE
REPRESENTATIVES IN THEIR LOCAL
EMERGENCY OFFICES- THEIR
EMERGENCY CENTERS TO. IMPROVE
THE COORDINATION AT A LOCAL
LEVEL ABOUT WHAT IS GOING ON
WITHIN THE P. JEANNIE SYSTEM.
THAT THAT THAT THAT'S THAT
DOESN'T THAT DOESN'T ANSWER MY
QUESTION I'M SORRY- OKAY LET'S
TRY AGAIN ARE DO YOU HAVE A
LEAK DO YOU ARE THERE IS THERE
SOMEONE THAT A SYSTEMS PERSON
CAN CALL AND SAY OKAY. HERE WE
ARE WE'RE READY TO WE RE
ENERGIZED ARE SO WE WE'VE GOT
OUR SYSTEM CLEAN- YOU DON'T
YOU. CURRENTLY DON'T HAVE THE
SEXUALIZATION IN THESE AREAS
YEAH SO. I KNOW THAT YOU I KNOW
THAT I UNDERSTAND THAT- YOU
CONSIDER THE MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES A SINGLE CUSTOMER
EVEN THOUGH THEY MAY REPRESENT.
YOU KNOW IN ONE CASE ELEVEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE ANOTHER CASE
SIXTEEN THOUSAND AND SO WANT TO
CONSIDER THEM ONE PERSON WANT
ONE CUSTOMER. AND THAT CUSTOMER
IS GOT READY TO GO BUT- FOR
WHATEVER REASON YOU DON'T HAVE
THE ABILITY TO CALL NUMBER ONE
COMMUNICATE WITH THEM. ON AND
GIVE THEM REAL TIME INFORMATION
AND EVER TO THE FLIP THE SWITCH
SO I'M JUST ASKING. BECAUSE IT
REPRESENTS NOT ALL SIXTEEN OF
THOSE ARE IN HIGH FIRES BUT
THAT REPRESENTS SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. SO I'M ASKING WHAT
ARE YOU DOING TO MAKE THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS. SO THAT THERE IS
A WAY FOR PEOPLE TO COMMUNICATE
AND GET INFORMATION AND WILL
YOU BE LOOKING TO SECTIONAL
EYES THOUGH SO THAT BECAUSE
THEY'VE ALREADY DONE THE LINE
WORK FOR YOU. THEIR LINES ARE
CLEAN THEY KNOW THEY'RE CLEAN
BECAUSE THEY'VE INSPECTED IN
THEMSELVES A YET YEAH THEY'RE
WAITING OFTENTIMES MUCH YOU
KNOW WELL PASS BIG CITIES
AROUND THERE THAT ARE THAT ARE
THAT ARE BEING RE ENERGIZED AND
THEY'RE NOT BEING RE ENERGIZED.
AND IT'S REALLY FRUSTRATING YES
YEAH WE UNDERSTAND AND WE
APPRECIATE THIS FEEDBACK WE
HEARD IT FOR OUR COMMUNITIES
THIS WAS SOMETHING WE- CAN DO
BETTER THAN WE DID IN TWENTY
NINETEEN SO. THERE'S A COUPLE
OF ASPECTS WHAT YOU ASKED THEIR
ONE IS DO THEY HAVE A- CONTACT
SO THEY KNOW WHO TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING IN OUR
GRADE- AND WHEN THINGS ARE
EXPECTED TO BE RE ENERGIZED.
AND SO WE'RE WORKING ON WHAT IT
IS. AT THE COUNTY LEVEL WHICH
SOMETIMES THESE MUNICIPAL. BY
UTILITY ARE PART COUNTY
GOVERNMENT WE HAVE YOU'RE
WORKING ON THE SINGLE POINT OF
CONTACT DEBBIE SHOULD. WORK
THESE AS IN THE GOAL TO MARKET
AS A- WORKING ON WHAT IS SINGLE
CONTACT WE HAVEN'T. FULLY NAIL
THAT DOWN YEP WILL HAVE THAT
READY BY PM ISN'T WE APPRECIATE
THAT THAT'S A NEED THAT WE NEED
TO HAVE. THAT WE ASK THAT YOU.
YOU KNOW FOR SOME US WHO WHO.
SHARE THIS FIRST. THAT YOU GET
THAT INFORMATION TO US AS WELL
THAT WOULD BE THAT WOULD BE
REALLY HELPFUL YEAH- AND DO YOU
ARE YOU COUNTING WHEN YOU WHEN
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE- SINCE MY
LAST QUESTION- I WITH- WHEN
YOU'RE LOOKING HERE THE MOST.
IMPACTED MEMBER TAKE YOUR TIME
WE SHE AND I ARE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE TWO OF YOU THEN. SO
YEAH PRETTY SO ARE YOU- WHEN
YOU'RE COUNT WHEN YOU'RE
COUNTING- AFFECTED PEOPLE ARE
YOU IN THE AND THE MUNICIPAL
UTILITY AREAS ARE YOU COUNTING
THOSE PEOPLE AS AS AS AS
AFFECTED OR YOU JUST COUNTING
THE ONE CUSTOMER BECAUSE THAT
THAT'S THAT'S ALSO ONE CLEAR
YEAH SO FOR THE HONEST ANSWERS
FOR THE PURPOSES OF OUR
STATISTICS- REPORTS IT'S ONE
CUSTOMER RIGHT WE APPRECIATE
OUR OPERATIONS CENTER IS AWARE
THAT THERE ARE MANY MORE
CUSTOMERS AND THAT WE HAVE THE
SAME SITUATION WITH MASTER
METERS AN APARTMENT COMPLEXES
AND STUFF THEY SHOW UP AS ONE
CUSTOMER BUT WE KNOW. IN SOME
CASES OF A MOBILE HOME PARK
THERE COULD BE HUNDREDS OF-
PEOPLE SOMETIMES VERY SENSITIVE
CUSTOMERS BEHIND THAT- ONE
METER SO- WE VERY MUCH
ABSORBENT INCORPORATE INTO OUR
PLANNING HOW TO- GET THOSE
AREAS UP FASTER THAT CHALLENGE
WITH MANY OF THE MUNICIPALS-
MUNICIPAL ELECTRICAL PROVIDERS
ELECTRICITY PROVIDERS IS THAT
THEY'RE SERVED OFF OF
TRANSMISSION LINES RIGHT AND
OUR TRANSMISSION LINE ANALYSIS
OFTEN TAKES LONGER TO BE REALLY
CLEAR ON WHO'S IMPACTED OR
WHO'S NOT AND SO WE PUT A LOT
OF EFFORT INTO THAT AS WE GO
INTO OUR TWENTY TWENTY- PS PS
SEASON WERE INSTALLING
ADDITIONAL SECTIONAL ISING
DEVICES ON OUR TRANSMISSION
SYSTEM. AT THE TRANSMISSION
LEVEL TO ALLOW US TO CUT UP
THAT SYSTEM BUT SOMETIMES
REFERRED TO AS THE YOU KNOW
BACKBONE SYSTEM TO BE ABLE TO
ROUTE REROUTE POWER TO KEEP AND
TRANSMISSION LEVEL CUSTOMERS
LIKE A MUNICIPAL ELECTRIC
PROVIDER ENERGIZED SO THAT'S
ONE OF THE ASPECTS THE OTHER
THING- DEBBIE MENTIONED BRIEFLY
EARLIER WE ARE- ACCORDING TO
FIXED WING AIRCRAFT THIS YEAR
WITH INFRARED CAMERAS SO THAT
WE CAN INSPECT THAT NIGHT WHICH
IS USUALLY NOT POSSIBLE- ON OUR
SYSTEM BUT WE CAN INSPECT
TRANSMISSION LINES AT NIGHT TO
GET THE GET THEM CLEARED HAVE
HAVE THE POWER TURNED ON
FASTER. AND LASTLY. FOR OUT
WITH THE LAST ONE WAS GONNA SAY
THERE'S ANOTHER TRANSMISSION-
EVER WE HAVE IN A WAY BUT I
FORGOT IT TO THE PUNCH LINE IS
WE APPRECIATE THAT THESE ARE
HIGH VALUE. CUSTOMERS EVEN IF
IT SHOWS UP ON OUR SYSTEM IS
ONE- IT HAS A LARGER IMPACT
THAN THAT AND SO WE PUT IN
PLACE MANY THINGS. ALL THE
LESSONS VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
WE'VE EXPANDED OUR VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT EFFORT ON
TRANSMISSION LINES BECAUSE THAT
CAN RAISE THE WIND THRESHOLD OR
THE WEATHER THRESHOLD. BEFORE
WE HAVE TO TAKE A P. S. P. S.
OUTAGE RIGHT BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT A WHOLE TRANSMISSION. THAT
THE WHOLE SUBSTATION WOULD BE
DOWN IF WE TAKE OUT CERTAIN
TRANSMISSION LINES SO WE'RE
WE'RE TAKING MANY ANGLES TO TRY
TO REDUCE THIS IMPACT WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THAT IT WAS. A
PAIN POINT OF FOR LARGE
CUSTOMERS IN LARGE ME. IN
TWENTY. FIVE I APPRECIATE THAT
AND I DO LIKE I SAID I WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW WHO THOSE CONTACT
PEOPLE WILL BE BECAUSE I WANNA
BE SURE THAT MY MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES. HAVE THAT CONTACT IN
MEXICAN TESTED OUT IN ADVANCE
BECAUSE- YOU KNOW THE IF THESE
ARE TRULY HIGH VALUE CUSTOMERS.
THEY SURE DON'T FEEL LIKE IT.
RIGHT NOW THEY'RE NOT REAL
HAPPY AND I KNOW IT SADLY I
KNOW THE TRANSMISSION LINES NOW
BETTER THAN I EVER EXPECTED TO
KNOW BECAUSE I'VE SPENT TIME
WITH THEM AND TRY TO UNDERSTAND
AND SOME OF THIS BAFFLE REALLY
BAFFLES OF THEM AND BAFFLES ME
AS TO WHY THEY WERE EVEN SHUT
OFF AND SOME OF THESE CASES AND
SO THAT'S WHY THIS SECTION WAS
ATION IS SUCH A CRITICAL THINGS
SPECIALLY FOR THE MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES WHO HAVE LIKE I SAID
HAVE DONE THEIR WORK. THEY'RE
RELYING ON YOU TO TRANSMIT THE
POWER AND THEY'RE THEY'RE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
DISTRIBUTION BUT THEY- THEY'VE
BEEN HAD A REALLY HARD TIME
COMMUNICATING WITH YOU GUYS AND
THAT'S JUST NOT ACCEPTABLE.
UNDERSTOOD THANK YOU OKAY JUST
TO CLARIFY. THEY WANT HE WANTS.
AND IF YOU HAVE MUNICIPAL BE
TELLING THESE I THINK IT'S THE
SAME THING. THAT THE MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES WILL BE ABLE TO TALK
DIRECTLY TO A SYSTEMS PERSON.
NOT A PR PERSON NOT THE PERSON
WHO'S IN THE EMERGENCY CENTER
TO SORT OF DO COORDINATION BUT
THE SYSTEM'S PERSON. WONDER
STANDS THE LINES SO IS THAT
CLEAR. THAT IS CLEAR OKAY GOOD.
RIGHT. NEXT HIGHLY IMPACTED.
I'M SORRY I HAVE P. GINNY
INVENT I HAVE FIVE COUNTIES UP
AND PLAY LOWER TIME AND FOR
LETTER DIFFERENTLY I'M NOT
GONNA PINPOINT TOTALLY UP GINNY
BUT I WILL SAY I HAVE FAITH
THAT I TO FACE. THAT WENT FOR
DAY WITH POWER IN FOR EIGHT
DAYS IN LATE COUNTY ON EXCEPT
WHEN THERE WAS NO WIND THERE
WAS NOTHING AND NO RESPONSE AND
I'M GOING FOR OF FORWARD I'M MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THE P. GINNY
HAS BEEN UP THERE TO TALK TO
SOME OF THE RESIDENTS ON FOR
SUB STATIONS THAT ARE READY TO
GO WHEN WE NEED A LOT MORE BUT
THE POINT BEING IS THAT THEY
GOT TWO DIFFERENT STORIES FROM
TWO DIFFERENT PEOPLE THE VICE
PRESIDENT TOLD THEM ABOUT THE
FOR SUBSTATIONS GAVE THEM A
DIFFERENT ANSWER THAN THE
PRESIDENT DID. SO I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THE COMMUNICATION IS
CLEAR TO MY SUBMERGED TO
SERVICES UP THERE ALL THE FIRE
DEPARTMENTS EVERYBODY'S WONDER
WHAT'S HAPPENING THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT I CAN'T GO AS MUCH
THURMOND SAID CONTINUED HAVE
SCHOOL CLOSED AND OUR ADA
SUFFERS FROM IT ID NUMBER LIKE
A SUFFERING AND DISTRICTS OF MY
SO THAT'S ONE OF THEM THE OTHER
ONE THE JET THERE'S A I KNOW
YOU DON'T SO JENNA. I DON'T
OPEN ISSUE DOING AND GENERATOR
OF BUSINESS BUT THE FOR THE
MATTER IS THAT EVERY CHEN TO DO
SIZE AND WHEN I HEAR SOMEONE'S
WE'RE GOING HELP HIM OUT WITH
THE CHEN REGENERATE WHEN YOU'RE
TRYING TO GET BACK OF PRESSURE
ON IS TO IT'S ON A WELL YOU
KNEW A DIFFERENT KIND OF CHEN
NOT JUST HOME DEPOT TÁI
GENERATE AND I SOMETIMES BE.
PUT THAT UNDER ONE HUGE
UMBRELLA THAT GOTTEN CHEN GRAY
THAT'S IN A GEN PUMP OR A WELL
I'M IN IN THE LAST ONE IS THE
WE HAVE KALRA COMMUNITY UP
THERE IN LAKE COUNTY AS WELL AS
THROUGHOUT THE DAY AS MUCH AS
JUST GO TO MAIL A WE CAN LOOK
AT MANY OF MY WELL DON'T EVEN
INTERNET. WHEN I HAVE FAMILIES
THAT. DON'T THEIR LIVING OFF OF
A- FOOD STAMPS OR WHATEVER AND
THEY HAVE NO FOOD. AND THE
REFRIGERATORS THEY HAVE TO
CLEAR OUT AND TRYING TO RE
COOP. IS VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE
FOR THE COMMUNITY SO- ONLY TO
PUT A FACE TO THOSE PEOPLE.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT THEY
THEY DON'T FORGET WE UNDERSTAND
THAT EVERYTHING WHEN YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO BUT THERE'S
PEOPLE. BEHIND ALL THIS SO
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT ARM. THE
MEDIA LET'S SEE IS THERE
ANYONE- MISTER MURATSUCHI YOU
HAVE QUESTION OKAY WELL I THINK
WE FINISHED WITH QUESTIONS I'D
LIKE YOU AS A ANEL TO STAY
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT I'D LIKE THE PUBLIC
COMMENT TO BE NO LONGER THAN
TWO MINUTES AND- IF THERE ARE
QUESTIONS THE FROM THE PUBLIC
COMMENT THAT YOU CAN ANSWER-
WILL TAKE THEM DOWN- SECRETARY
WILL- TAKE DOWN QUESTIONS. AND
WILL HAVE THE MANSARD AFTER
THAT PUBLIC COMIC GOES THROUGH.
ALL RIGHT- PUBLIC COMMENT
PLEASE STAND IN RONT OF THE-
MICROPHONE AND. AND I'LL GIVE
YOU WARNING AT TWO MINUTES CAN
JUST FINISH UP YOUR SERVANTS.
RIGHT COULD HAVE I AM STAYS
HEATING WITH WORLD RIGHT OF CAL.
WE REPRESENT THIRTY SEVEN RURAL
COUNTIES STATEWIDE AND WE HAVE
A LOT OF WILD FIRE EVENS IN OUR
MEMBER COUNTIES LIKE A LOT A
LOT AND WE HAVE BEEN PROFOUNDLY
IMPACTED. BY THE PUBLIC SAFETY
POWERSHOT OFFICE OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL MONTHS AND- WE'RE ALSO
HEAVILY INVOLVED IN THE UC-
PROCEEDINGS ON BOTH THE WELFARE
MITIGATION PLANS AND THE DINNER
DE INTERNALIZATION EVENTS AND
SO I WON'T GO TOO DEEPLY INTO
WHAT OUR COMMENTS HAVE BEEN BUT
I WILL STRESS THAT- ONE OF OUR
BIG COMMENTS HAS BEEN THAT WE
JUST NEED TO KEEP COMMUNICATION
GOING EARLY AND OFTEN. WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WE RUN A LOT
OF- CRITICAL FACILITIES THAT
REALLY NEED INFORMATION EARLY
AND OFTEN IN AT PS PS EVENTS-
INCLUDING YOU KNOW JAILS
HOSPITALS- WATER MANAGEMENT-
ALL SORTS OF THINGS COUNTY
ELECTION OFFICES IF IT OF
INVENTORS GONNA BUT- UP AGAINST
AN- I CAN. FIRE WAS A DANGER OF
DOING AND THEN WE A YOU KNOW
IT'S OVER ISSUE SO ALL SORTS OF
THINGS THAT MAYBE WE DIDN'T
THINK OF BEFORE ALSO. THE
COMMUNITY RESOURCE CENTER WE'RE
STILL READY TO WERE WITH YOU ON
HELPING THOSE UP SO THAT
THEY'RE A LITTLE BETTER MANDAN
MANAGED THAN THEY WERE IN
PREVIOUS EVENTS WE HAD A LOT OF
OUR RESIDENTS- COMPLAINING
ABOUT. SORT OF NOT THEM NOT
BEING ADEQUATE FOR ESPECIALLY
THE AFN POPULATIONS TO BE ABLE
TO GO AND CHARGE THEIR
EQUIPMENT LIKE THEY NEEDED TO-
YOU KNOW NEEDING THEM TO BE
OPEN TWENTY FOUR HOURS THAT
SORT OF THING. SO THERE'S A LOT
OF WORK WE FEEL LIKE WE CAN
HELP YOU WITH AND WE JUST WANT
TO BE PARTNERS WITH YOU ON THIS
TO HELP SERVE OUR RESIDENTS
YOUR CUSTOMERS. AND TO KEEP
THOSE LINES OF COMMUNICATION
OPEN THANK YOU. MA'AM YES SIR-
SO HOW WOULD YOU SUGGEST THAT
THIS DIALOGUE CONTINUE WELL
WE'RE ACTIVELY IN MEETINGS MOST
OF OUR MEMBERSHIP IS IN P.
JEANNIE AND I SOCAL EDISON. SO
WE'RE ACTIVELY MEETING WITH-
BOTH COMPANIES RIGHT NOW AND
THAT TALKING OFF LINE AND ALSO
SUBMIT LIKE I SAID SOMEBODY OUR
COMMENTS BUT- DIRECTLY COMMUTE-
COMMUNICATING WITH THE COUNTIES
THE COUNTY ADMINISTRATIVE
OFFICES. EARLY AND OFTEN- THAT
ADMINISTER THOSE FACILITIES- SO
THAT THEY CAN GET THE
INFORMATION OUT TO THEIR
RESIDENTS BECAUSE THE COUNTIES
HAVE METHODS TO DO THAT ALREADY
IN PLACE- SO THAT THEY CAN GET
THAT INFORMATION OUT I THINK
IT'S- REALLY. IMPORTANT REALLY
CRUCIAL UP FRONT. OKAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU. YEAH NEW CREDIT
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATUS IS OF COUNTIES-
DEFINITELY ONE ECHO WHAT STACY
JUST SAID FROM RC RC- OUR
MEMBERS ARE IT'S A TOP PRIORITY
FOR MEMBERS PARTICULARLY THE P.
S. P. S. ISSUE ON IT DEFINITELY
IMPACTS A LOT OF OUR MEMBERS
CONSTITUENTS- BUT MOVING-FORWARD YOU KNOW THE FOCUS-REALLY THAT WE THINK SHOULD BE
ON THE MITIGATION EFFORTS THAT
YOU HAVE DETAILED HERE TODAY
WAS YOU KNOW REALLY GOOD HERE
THE DETAILS ON THAT- AND THAT
IN THE EVENT OF HAVING. USE THE
P. S. P. S. SHUT DOWN IT SHOULD
BE A LAST RESORT- IN IN THOSE
CASES YOU KNOW WE SUPPORT- A
COUPLE OF A COUPLE THINGS WHEN
THIS P. HAS VINCE HAPPENS WHEN
DO. I'M THAT BE BETTER SHARING
SO RELY TIME ACCURATE
INFORMATION FOR OUR YES
MANAGERS ARE PUBLIC SAFETY
FOLKS AGAIN JUST KIND OF WILL
STACY WAS SAYING THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT HELPS US
WITH COMMUTING HELPS MANAGE-
AND ALSO TO OFFERING TO BE A
RESOURCE FOR YOU AS WELL AS YOU
KNOW WE HAVE CONNECTIONS AND
COMMUNITY- WERE HAPPY
COORDINATE WITH YOU ON TRYING
TO GET TO A PLACE WHERE YOU
KNOW THE NOTIFICATION YOUR
PROVIDING ARE HITTING YOU CAN
BE THAT YOU NEED THEM. TODAY A
BIG OF A PORTION OF THAT IS WHY
ON THE COMMITTEE RESOURCE AS
WELL- YOU KNOW TRYING TO GET
THOSE MORE IN PLACES THAT CAN
BE BROADER YOU KNOW A LITTLE
BIT MORE HELPFUL FOR
CONSTITUENTS ON THE SOMETHING
AT THE REPLY WERE FOR MOVING
FORWARD BUT WE DO WE STAND
READY TO HELP YOU AS PARTNER
I'M BECAUSE IT IS A REALLY
IN THE AND THE THAT ARE MEMBERS
REPRESENT. THANK YOU. YOU HAVE.
AND NOT SEE HER NAME. ON BEHALF
OF THE U. REFORM THAT. OR TURN
JUST. THINGS OUT TURN CURRENTLY
IN THE- OF REVIEWING IN DETAIL.
ALL OF THE MITIGATION- PLANS
AND- OFFICE INVOLVED IN THE
PROCEEDINGS- AT THE COMMISSION-
WE TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY THE NEED
TO. MITIGATE THE RISKS AND
PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY. AND AS
WE'RE DOING THIS WORK WE ARE
LOOKING AT AND KIND OF WHAT WAS
TALKED ABOUT TODAY- THE PART
PRIORITIZE YOU KNOW. HOW TO
MITIGATE RISK- HOW TO APPROACH
IN WHICH AREAS BUT ALSO WHICH
TOOLS. ARE GONNA BE MOST
EFFECTIVE IN CERTAIN AREAS.
UNDER CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES.
AND ALSO WHETHER ONE TOOL IS
MORE EFFECTIVE- THEN ANOTHER
TOOL IN CERTAIN SITUATIONS SO
WE HAVE TO BE VERY CAREFUL THAT
WE HEAR ABOUT A LOT OF GOOD
TOOLS. BUT WE HAVE TO GO MUCH
DEEPER THAN THAT THAT'S THE
WORK THAT WE'RE DOING RIGHT NOW
THE COMMISSION'S MAKE SURE.
THAT THE MEDICARE. PLAN TO
REALLY PART OF A REALLY- REALLY
STRATEGIZE. VERY SPECIFIC-
APPROACHES TO MITIGATE THE
RISKS. IN IN DOING IN DOING
THIS WE'RE LOOKING AT A FEW
DIFFERENT THINGS JUST. SOME
EXAMPLES- JEANNIE OVERALL PLAN
AND- IS ENDING FOUR POINT FIVE
BILLION MORE THAN. AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON. AND YET
THERE'S LESS MONEY BEING. AND
STATE IN. A NUMBER OF THINGS
INCLUDING- THE INSULATION OR
COVER DOCTORS AND IN YOU KNOW
IN OTHER MATTER SO WE- TRY TO.
OUT YOU KNOW WHY IT WHY. STRAT
ARE BEING EMPLOYED. AT CERTAIN
ANSWER NAY. SO THAT'S THAT.
THAT WERE DUE RIGHT NOW. WE'RE
LOOKING AT WHETHER OR NOT
TECHNOLOGY IS BEING UTILIZED A
NEW TECHNOLOGIES PROTEIN
BROUGHT IN- AT A PACE THAT IS
APPROPRIATE- FOR THE RISK THAT
IS OUT THERE SO THOSE ARE
THINGS THAT WE'RE LOOKING. OUT
AND WE'LL BE TALKING ABOUT.
LOOKING AT THE REMOVAL OF
HEALTHY TREES ALL THAT. BY
ITSELF MAY BE A GOOD STRATEGY.
BY WHEN YOU LOOK AT OTHER
STRATEGIES AND OTHER TOOLS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE. YOU KNOW IS
THERE IS KIND OF A SLIDING
SCALE SHOULD PUT MORE RESOURCES
MAYBE INTO SOMETHING ELSE IN
CERTAIN AREAS- AS OPPOSED TO
MOVING SOME. HEALTHY TREE SO
THOSE THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT VERY. AND THE LAST
THING A MAN IS KEEP HIM. THAT
WERE ALL LOOK AND OTHERS A
QUESTION OF SOME. MARK
MURATSUCHI ABOUT THE RATE PAYER.
I IMPACT WEEK WE OBVIOUSLY HAVE
TO LOOK AT THAT AS- AND- ONE
ANGLE IT WILL LOOK AT IS. ARE
SOME OF THE ACTIVE. ARE THEY
REALLY OF NEW MAY. EFFORTS OR
THEY JUST SIMPLY. CATCH UP. ON
TRYING TO FIX- DISTRIBUTION
LINES AND GET AND COMPLIANCE.
I'M A WITH MINIMUM STANDARDS
THAT SHOULD HAVE ALREADY BEEN
MATT. AND MONEY HAD ALREADY
BEEN EXPANDED TO DO SOME OF
THIS WORK BUT DID BUT NOT ALL
THE WORK WAS DONE. SO THOSE ARE
THINGS WERE LOOKING AT- AS THE
PLANS ARE BEING EVALUATED. OF
WHETHER OR NOT SOME OF THIS
EVEN FITS INTO MITIGATION PLAN-
AND THEN SHOULD BE EVALUATED
THAT WAY OR SHOULD BE EVALUATED
THAT IS REALLY PLAYING CATCH UP
ON WORK THAT WASN'T DONE
BEFORE. SO WE'RE DOING THE
TOUGH WORK OF ASK THE TOUGH
QUESTIONS. ABOUT THE END OF THE
DAY TO PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY
BUT ALSO TO PROTECT REPAIR SO
WHEN THANK YOU FOR THE WORK
TODAY AND- CERTAIN WILL
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE WITH BOTH
THE COMMITTEE AND ALSO WITH.
ALL THE PANELISTS AND COMPANIES
ARE INVOLVED. YOU. THANK YOU
FOR THIS HEARING TODAY NAME IS.
HARMON I'M THE GENERAL. OF GO.
ZERO IT'S IN AN- COMPANY. I
WOULD I THINK SO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBER STAFF. BENEATH WITH US
TODAY TALKING ABOUT ONE OF OUR
SOLUTIONS. IF YOU DON'T KNOW
GOALS YOU'RE PRODUCES SOLAR
CHARGEABLE IN ZERO EMISSIONS
PORTABLE POWER STATIONS THAT
CAN HELP PEOPLE. AND A- FULL
DURING THESE PORTABLE BUT THE
THESE PSP EVENTS- WE WANT TO
THANK BOTH. ESTY JEANNIE AND
PGA ANY FURTHER PARTNERSHIP.
WITH US DEPLOYING THESE TO
MEDICAL BASELINE CUSTOMER
STARTING LAST YEAR AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO EXPANDING THAT THIS
YEAR IT'S ALREADY HAPPENING AS
WE SPEAK THERE'S A LOT MORE
THAT WE CAN DO TO IMPACT A LOT
MORE PEOPLE. BUT WE'RE SEEING
THAT EXPANSION. IF YOU WEREN'T
AWARE OF WHAT THESE POWER
STATIONS ARE JUST A COUPLE
QUICK WORDS ABOUT THEM- WE CAN
POWER EVERYTHING FROM CELL
PHONES- TWO REFRIGERATORS AND
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT WITH THESE.
ZERO EMISSIONS- ZERO GASOLINE
REQUIRED NO PULLING THE RED
CHORD IN HOPING THE THING
STARTS IN ACTUALLY DELIVERS FOR
ME WHEN I NEED IT NO FUMES NO
FOSSIL FUELS. I'M WE OBSERVED
ABOUT A 1000% INCREASE. IN OUR
SALES LAST OCTOBER DURING THE
PSP EVENTS- TO CALIFORNIA
SPECIFICALLY I THINK THIS
SPEAKS. TO BOTH THE PILOT WORK
SDG IT AND GREEN P. JEANNIE OF
DONE WITH US. WITH THAT PA.
RESULTS JUST. BECAUSE VOTING
WITH THEIR- GOES LONG WAY TELL
YOU THAT THE SOLUTION. WORKS
FOR THEM. I'M MORE AVAILABLE AS
A RESOURCE TO TALK MORE ABOUT
HOW THE SOLUTIONS CAN HELP
DURING. WILDFIRES IN PSP
EVENTS- WE ALSO JUST SO YOU
KNOW HAVE A- A DEMONSTRATION OF
THAT GOING ON RIGHT NOW DOWN ON
THE SOUTH STEPS WERE HAPPY TO
SHOW YOU THE SOLUTION IF YOU
AREN'T AWARE OF WHAT A PORTABLE
POWER STATION IS. ONLY ABOUT
13% OF CALIFORNIANS KNOW. THAT
THE SOLUTION EVEN EXIST. MANY
PEOPLE WALK AROUND THINKING THE
ONLY WAY. I CAN GET POWER INTO
MY HOME IS A GAS GENERATOR- A
THE COMES WITH MANY OF THE
CONSEQUENCES WE TALKED ABOUT.
SO WE WOULD LOVE TO SHOW YOU
MORE AND MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
REALLY EDUCATE EVERYONE ON WHAT
THE SOLUTIONS CAN DO. THANK YOU
I APPRECIATE THE TIME. THANK
YOU DO ANY OF THE PANELISTS
HAVE A DISH. COM. GOT GO AHEAD
GO JUST LIKE EXPRESS OUR THANKS
HAVING TO HEAR OF THE IN THE
COMMUNITY FEEDBACK AS WELL THIS
IS IMPORTANT FORCE TO DO AS
WELL- I DO WANT TO MENTION ONE
THING WE TALKED ABOUT HOW LONG
TO GET THERE JUST A BIT JUST
POINT IS SIMPLY ALSO TO THE
WALL FIRE MITIGATION PLANS WERE
ALL REQUIRED TO FILE SOME THE
CALL THE MATURITY MATRIX. THAT
WILL WILL MONITOR AND MEASURE
HOW WE INTEND TO PROGRESS
BECAUSE I THINK A LOT OF THIS
IS ARE WE MAKING THE BEST USE
ARE WE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE
TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE AVAILABLE
TO US AND PRACTICES THAT ARE
OUT THERE SO I THINK THERE ARE
THINGS THAT WE ARE PUTTING IN
PLACE NOW TO GIVE US. MAYBE AN
EXTERNAL WAY OF ASSESSING OUR
PROGRESS AS WE CONTINUE TO MAKE
ASSISTANCE MORE SAFE RIGHT IN
DO SO P. JEANNIE AND- EDISON DO
YOU HAVE- HOW CAN. LINKS TO ALL
THE- COUNTIES THAT COUNTY. THE
CAME UP COUNTY AND- COUNTIES A
WHOLE. YOU HAVE LINKS TO ALL OF
THEM. THAT TO. GREAT ALL RIGHT
WELL FOR YOU ALL VERY MUCH I'M
GOING TO. IN A TO THIS HE. HEY
MEGAN GET YEAH. OKAY.